nous sommes heureux d'accueillir
Monsieur Philippe Diallo président par
intérim de la Fédération Française de
Football ainsi que monsieur Alexandre
Martinez président par intérim de la
Fédération française de rugby je les
remercie évidemment de leur présence
avec nous ce matin
s'il vous plaît vous représentez deux
des plus grosses fédérations sportives
françaises
qui abrite de formes équipes nationales
mes collègues se joignent ainsi à moi
pour saluer la qualité de l'équipe de
France de football qui CIC en finale de
la dernière Coupe du monde et nous
sommes nombreux je crois à souhaiter le
même destin voir un peu plus encore pour
l'équipe de France de rugby qui bien sûr
participera à la Coupe du Monde qui
tiendra tout le monde le sait dans notre
pays dans quelques mois
je n'oublie pas par ailleurs le rôle de
vos fédérations pour développer la
pratique de vos sports auprès des plus
jeunes c'est une dimension qui
évidemment
nous intéresse tout particulièrement
dans cette commission puisque nous
sommes également la commission
d'éducation physique et sportive cette
audition intervient un peu plus d'un an
après l'adoption de la loi du 2 mars
2022 visant à démocratiser le sport en
France
cette loi qui comprenait de nombreuses
dispositions visant à moderniser la
gouvernance des fédérations sportives
nous souhaiterions connaître l'état de
la mise en oeuvre de cette loi qui
nécessitera des modifications
statutaires pour de nombreuses
fédérations nous ne serions
ignorés évidemment que vos deux
fédérations ont traversé des crises de
gouvernance ces derniers mois Chris
complètement fini où nous en direz
évidemment un mot quels enseignements en
tirez-vous plus précisément alors que la
ministre des Sports vient engager une
large concertation qui pourrait aboutir
à de nouvelles modifications
législatives à l'horizon de 2025
quels sont selon vous les chantiers
prioritaires pour permettre à
vos deux fédérations de mieux
fonctionner
je souhaiterais également mentionner un
dernier sujet d'actualité qui concerne
l'avenir du Stade de France et pour
lequel vos deux fédérations sont
évidemment directement concernées l'état
vient de lancer une double consultation
portant d'une part sur une nouvelle
concession d'exploitation et d'autre
part sur une session du stade
l'arbitrage entre l'un ou l'autre des
modèles n'étant pas encore effectués par
l'État ces deux consultations prévoient
je cite que l'exploitation du stade
devra permettre l'accueil prioritaire
des événements organisés par la
Fédération Française de Rugby à la
Fédération Française de Football comment
voyez-vous l'avenir de ce stade est-ce
que vous vous êtes concerté pour définir
une position commune est-ce que vous
examinez la possibilité de participer
activement à cette double consultation
pour déposer soit une offre d'achat soit
une offre portant sur une concession
d'exploitation vous voyez les sujets
d'actualité ne manquent pas je vais vous
la parole dans quelques secondes pour
une un propos introductif d'une dizaine
de minutes après quoi je proposerai à
Michel Savin président du groupe
d'études sur les pratiques sportives et
les grands événements sportifs de vous
proposer une première série de de
questions et puis après bien entendu
chacun des chacune des sénatrices et
chacun des sénateurs qui le souhaitent
pourront également vous interroger et
enfin je rappelle que cette audition est
captée et diffusée sur le site internet
du Sénat Messieurs les Présidents je
vous cède la parole je ne sais pas qui
commence c'est la figure rugby
bon c'est le président monsieur le
Président de la Fédération Française de
foot mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
vous l'avez rappelé je suis président
je me qualifie moi-même d'apprenti
président intérimaire
oh pardon donc je vais reprendre donc
je reprends comme ça je regagne une
minute
donc j'ai été en présentation je suis
avec San Martinez donc président par
intérim de Fédération française de rugby
pardon et je me présente comme apprenti
président intérimaire ce qui doit
quelque part bien fixer les idées et cet
exercice étant pour moi
nouveau je compte sur votre
bienveillance tolérance bienveillante
tolérance voilà
[Musique]
l'audience le thème de l'audience tel
que je l'ai perçu était éthique et
gouvernance initialement donc
j'ai décidé de vous raconter un peu mon
arrivée à la Fédération Française de
Rugby qui indirectement posera ces
questions parce que je pense que c'est
aussi un élément important de d'une des
réponses
à la question posée au sujet de
l'audience donc je serai en 2016 à la
faveur de l'élection de l'équipe Bernard
Laporte
je t'ai retraité depuis deux ans 2014 et
je suis
un ancien cas dirigeant d'un grand
groupe français Orange français
et je suis arrivé plutôt parce que j'ai
beaucoup de rugby dans ma jeunesse et
c'est un sport qui est en général
passionne et dans le cas présent ma
passionné toute ma vie et je me suis
retrouvé donc serviteur du rugby en tant
que président d'un club de rugby qui est
le club de Lavaur alors pour ceux qui ne
situent pas la voir d'avoir dans le Tarn
Toulouse est à côté de lavande
d'ailleurs
et
j'étais présente en disant et cette
expérience assemblée pertinente ce qui
fait que lors de la campagne de Bernard
Laporte j'ai été Copé pour la compétence
de campagne et je me suis retrouvé à
l'issue de cette campagne parfois
tumultueuse
comme dirigeant du rugby France en tant
que trésorier donc post important si
l'année et voilà comment on se retrouve
très Aurier dirigeant de rugby français
alors quand on arrive à la Fédération
dans les conditions dans lesquelles nous
sommes arrivés
bonne et de suite confronté parce qu'on
arrive en plus au mois de décembre c'est
en pleine période sportive on se trouve
on se trouve confronté immédiatement au
quotidien de la Fédération c'est à dire
que sachant que le quotidien c'est quoi
c'est s'occuper de sport pour tout enfin
du rugby pour tous c'est-à-dire le rugby
amateur qui produit plusieurs milliers
de matchs par week-end et confronté
aussi
de nos autres missions que la gestion du
rugby d'élite c'est-à-dire le tournoi
des 6 nations qui pointe son horizon
de la fin janvier
et on se trouve confronté donc à essayer
de faire vivre cette fédération sans
forcément voir sans du tout y avoir été
préparé
et en s'opposant les questions de
gouvernance comment gouverne une
fédération
les questions d'éthique quel est
l'éthique on doit mettre en oeuvre alors
bien sûr dans notre propre moral mais
notre moral n'est jamais que
l'expression de notre expérience tant
professionnelle que sportive et aussi de
notre éducation dans laquelle le rugby a
joué un rôle mais enfin on se retrouve
confronté à ça c'est-à-dire voilà
comment comment on doit prendre alors on
a des outils on a des outils des outils
qui sont le code du sport
les autorismes bien marqués pour un
nouveau dirigeant on a
les statues et les règlements de la
fédération
qui ont un caractère juridique là aussi
alors qu'il confère peut-être un peu
moins lesotérisme mais enfin qu'on ne
sait pas toujours lire quand on n'a pas
une formation juridique on a des
instances une assemblée générale on a un
bureau fédéral
nous sommes générale que sur une île
deux fois par an un comité directeur
pendant que je suis revenu trois fois
par an un bureau fédéral qui se réunit
une dizaine de fois par an
et on doit toujours faire face au
quotidien d'une fédération et le
quotidien génère des questions
auxquelles on doit répondre quasi
instantanément parce que autrement mais
on est on est rapidement débordé on a
aussi une structure une structure qui
est composée de salariés qui ont la
compétence
et le dévouement et la motivation
pour autant se pose la question de la
relation et lui salarié pour quelqu'un
qui n'a jamais été élu comme c'était le
cas
dans tout ça pour dire que lorsqu'on
arrive dans une fédération bien la
question de la gouvernance
se pose ça de l'été que se pose
également mais on ne sait pas forcément
trop bien y répondre et on y répond son
propre référentiel c'est à dire comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure l'expérience
et puis au fil du temps on découvre que
les choses les choses il y a plein de
choses qui existent il y a plein de
pratiques il y a plein de coutumes il y
a la tradition et dans le rugby le rugby
riche en tradition
et là au fur et à mesure qu'on avance
mais on prend conscience que tel sujet
on aurait dû peut-être le traité
différemment parce que les instances de
gouvernance nous oblige nous obliger à
le traiter différemment faire s'aperçoit
qu'on fait des erreurs
et que ces erreurs ben une fois qu'elles
sont faites sont un peu soit on peut pas
les rattraper
tout ça pour dire que
un vrai sujet pour moi qui est peut-être
une amorce de réponse à la question
posée
même s'il y a des textes et les textes
sont importants mais les textes de balle
que par la maison dont on les applique
et pour moi on voit ce sujet c'est une
équipe nouvelle
comment
les sélectionner quelles sont les
compétences de ce cercles pour Jérôme
fédération et comment quelque part on
introduit cette équipe nouvelle dans la
gestion d'une fédération à travers
peut-être des
formations un peu tout imaginer enfin je
pense que vous devenez bien avec le sens
de mon propos
et ces choses-là n'existent pas on
devient de fait autodidacte
je trouve que c'est ça présente un
intérêt alors pourtant vous allez me
dire
et vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
les résultats aujourd'hui de notre
équipe de France sont plutôt
intéressants
on introduit
une autre forme de gouvernance dans le
système puisque aujourd'hui 100% on a
plus de grands électeurs on a fait des
100% des clubs contribuent à l'élection
des dirigeants de la fédé donc on a
introduit une
démocratie je dirais totale
on a aujourd'hui des clubs qui sont
plutôt qui semblent plutôt satisfaits de
la manière dont les choses sont gérées à
la Fédération donc globalement les
résultats sont nous ont pas si mal alors
c'est surtout pas pour mettre en avant
la performance de l'équipe en place que
je dis ça mais tout ça pour dire que
on avait peut-être aussi que Monsieur
Jourdain de la prose en savoir en gérant
le fédération selon les canons qui
devraient être qui seuls les canons
entendus
donc
on est aujourd'hui sur le chantier vous
l'avez évoqué de la mise en oeuvre de
Lola sur le sport je vous expliquerai
tout à l'heure c'est des questions à ce
sujet Comment on essaie s'organiser mais
je pense que avant toute chose il faut
peut-être préparer les équipes qui
arrivent aujourd'hui
comme dirigeant de la Fédération parce
que en tout cas l'expérience que j'ai
vécu je suis depuis septembre maintenant
m'amène à penser que notre niveau de
préparation était pas satisfaisant et
que non peut-être
commis des erreurs
qu'on a peut-être
contribuer à connaître la crise sociale
que vous évoquez tout à l'heure la crise
de la Fédération que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en introduction je passe la parole
au ballon rond
merci
je suis le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices je vais
essayer d'avoir un propos peut-être
complémentaire à celui du président de
la fédération de rugby ont d'abord on
vous remercions de nous écouter sur ce
thème important de la gouvernance des
fédérations
qui a connu
dans nos disciplines respectives un
certain nombre de de tumulte sur ces
derniers mois et ces dernières années
donc il est important pour nous à la
fois d'en faire le constat et puis aussi
par rapport aux dispositif législatif
mis en place en mars 2022 de voir
comment ces dispositifs législatifs
répondent à nos préoccupations
si vous me permettez je voudrais faire
peut-être un tout petit point d'histoire
pour montrer un peu les évolutions de la
gouvernance s'agissant de la Fédération
française de football qui comme dans
d'autres domaines de la société
française avance souvent à l'occasion de
crise et
notre première crise de gouvernance dans
le dans les temps modernes elle remonte
à la Coupe du Monde
2010 ou peut-être certains d'entre vous
se souviennent que nos joueurs avaient
à la phase du monde refuser de descendre
d'un bus ce qui avait créé non seulement
un trouble sportif mais un une
dégradation de l'image de la France
compte tenu de la répercussion
médiatique d'une coupe du monde de
football
et parmi les causes évoquées à ce
moment-là ont été mis en avant la
question de la gouvernance de la
Fédération française de football qui
n'aurait plus correspondu à
ou nécessité aux obligations d'une
grande fédération en charge de budget
important dans un sport regroupant plus
de 2 millions de licenciés et ayant une
résonance internationale importante et
comme c'est parfois le cas à l'issue de
cette crise sportive c'est
enclencher une crise de gouvernance qui
a été qui a fait l'objet de la réunion
d'État généraux et donc l'ensemble des
représentants du football ce sont réunis
pour pouvoir déterminer qu'elle pourrait
être la meilleure gouvernance pour
éviter à l'avenir ce type de crise et
à cette occasion là il est sorti donc
une nouvelle gouvernance de la
Fédération française de football qui
reposait sur un certain nombre de grands
axes le premier axe c'était un exécutif
resserré puisque la précédente
gouvernance on avait entre 20 et 30
membres dans le comité exécutif et donc
l'idée avait été de dire il faut
resserrer l'exécutif de la Fédération
parce qu'on le resserrant on a plus de
chances d'avoir une plus grande agilité
une plus grande efficacité dans
l'exécutif de la fédération
deuxième point important on avait mis en
place un scrutin de liste
un scrutin de liste pourquoi parce que
c'était
la partait de la philosophie qu'une
liste c'est une tête de liste qui est le
leader mais que avec sa liste il
constitue une équipe et que cette équipe
allait porteuse d'un programme et donc à
travers cette tête de liste cette équipe
et ce programme l'idée était d'avoir une
cohérence
dans l'action fédérale donc un exécutif
resserré une équipe un programme et donc
une plus grande agilité et une cohérence
dans la direction de la fédération
c'est ce qui s'est mis en place en 2011
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et force cette constater que la mise en
place de dispositif a eu des résultats
probants sur la durée
probant parce que
vous avez bien voulu faire état des
résultats sportifs des équipes
nationales françaises elles sont je peux
le dire quelque part un âge d'or du
football français
7 tournois finaux mondiaux 4 fois la
France présence présente dans la finale
deux fois vainqueur
j'ai un âge qui me permet de dire qu'il
fut des époques où la question n'était
pas de savoir si on en aurait finale
c'était de savoir si on allait au
tournoi final et donc de ce point de vue
là un progrès incontestable du côté des
féminines euro en Angleterre notre
équipe féminine demi-finaliste de l'euro
et je pourrais évoquer les résultats des
équipes de jeunes et donc la France de
ce point de vue là et se pense que c'est
la mission de la Fédération c'est de
permettre à ces équipes à tous les
niveaux d'être les plus performants
possible
je pense que les résultats ont été
probants
sur le plan économique
là aussi la Fédération a connu c'est 10
dernières années une croissance de ces
revenus qui lui ont permis de financer
le développement de la pratique sport
tous et du football amateur pour la
première fois dans les dernières
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
Fédération la Fédération Française de
Football a été en capacité de verser
plus de 100 millions d'euros de franchir
la barre des 100 millions d'euros de
reversement au football amateur
mais je pense que la gouvernance qui
avait été mis en place de ces parts
entre guillemets limité à ces constats
sportifs ou économiques mais c'est
élargi aussi à
des aspects de démocratie lorsqu'on
regarde les différentes échéances
électorales avec ce scrutin de liste on
constate qu'il n'y a pas moins de 4
listes à chaque fois qui ont été
présentes permettant une assez grande
diversité
de la compétition électorale au sein de
notre fédération et permettant donc à
chacun
tous les quatre ans de pouvoir exprimer
son programme avec une équipe et une
tête de liste
sur le plan de la féminisation
aujourd'hui notre comité exécutif qui
est de 12 membres élus à 25 % de femmes
au sein de son comité exécutif et des
femmes qui n'ont pas simplement le rôle
de membre mais qui sont pour l'une très
orientaires de l'autre secrétaire
général ce qui veut dire que sur les
trois fonctions
généralement qualifiées c'est à dire de
vice-présidents trésorière secrétaire
général de sont occupés par des femmes
et précédemment la vice-présidente de la
Fédération française de football était
aussi une femme
donc ce sont de ce point de vue là je
pense à certains noms d'acquis qui font
que nos prédécesseurs lorsque ils ont
modifié les statuts de la fédération et
modifier la gouvernance
on me semble-t-il obtenu un certain
nombre de résultats probants dans les
différents domaines dans lequel une
fédération peut intervenir
en mars 2022 le législateur a souhaité
renforcer les éléments de démocratie à
travers un vote plus direct des clubs et
à introduire des principes de parité
pour là aussi renforcer les tendances
plus générales de la société qui vise à
permettre à des femmes de pouvoir
occuper des postes de
élus d'élus au sein de fédération donc
bien évidemment nous on s'inscrit dans
cette démarche et on la soutient donc il
n'est pas d'ambiguïté de ce point de vue
là et donc la Fédération Française a mis
en place depuis déjà plusieurs mois
certains nombre de groupes de travail
qui sont en charge de transposer les
dispositions législatives
dans nos statuts
du point de vue de la démocratisation
c'est à dire du vote des clubs nous
sommes entre guillemets dans des
dispositifs qui me semblent même si
c'est lourd puisque nous nous avons
14000 clubs
et donc c'est c'est une transposition et
une processus électorale qui n'est pas
si simple mais nos amis du rugby nous
ont montré la voie et donc nous le
ferons de même
en revanche il y a et je voulais si vous
me permettez
ça il y a deux ou trois points qui me
semblent pour nous appeler la vigilance
d'une part
je l'ai dit c'est pour ça que je me suis
permis de faire ce petit rappel
historique aujourd'hui notre comité
exécutif à 12 membres élus de membres de
droits mécaniquement les dispositions de
la loi de mars 2002 font qu'on va passer
à 28
mécaniquement et donc ça veut dire que
d'une certaine manière par rapport à
l'évolution historique que je vous ai
indiqué en ce qui concerne la Fédération
française de football c'est un retour à
avant 2010
et donc les notions que j'ai évoquées de
resserrement de l'exécutif d'agilité
nous interroge
parce que à 28 évidemment c'est moins
facile entre guillemets de pouvoir
diriger que lorsque vous êtes une équipe
d'une douzaine de personnes
le deuxième élément que je voulais
mettre en lumière c'est celui de la
parité
non pas sur la question du principe de
la parité mais des conséquences qu'elle
introduit dans le mécanisme tel qu'il a
été prévu par le législateur
dans les exécutifs des fédérations à
l'avenir il y a 7 personnes qualifiées
qui devront obligatoirement faire partie
de cet exécutif et qui devront avoir au
moins 25% des sièges
d'où mon 28 membres à minima
la difficulté qui nous est proposée
c'est que c'est cette personne
qualifiées qui sont donc des entraîneurs
des joueurs des Arbites des médecins
sont désignés par leur père
et donc quand vous présentez à
l'élection avec votre liste vous ne
savez pas a priori si c'est une homme ou
une femme qui va être désignée par ses
pairs par les Arbites par les joueurs
par les médecins et donc il y a là une
question de timing entre guillemets si
je peux me permettre cette expression
entre se désignation de cette personne
qualifiée
et la liste que vous devez constituer
puisque c'est l'ensemble du futur organe
directeur qui doit être paritaire et
donc ça veut dire que vous devez
attendre de savoir quelles sont ces sept
personnes qualifiées
quel est leur
genre pour pouvoir vous-même constituer
votre propre liste et donc si je pars de
cette base de 28 membres si par
hypothèse vous avez puisqu'il y a
forcément dans les sportifs de haut
niveau un homme et une femme ça veut
dire que vous avez 6 hommes ben ces six
hommes ça veut dire que sur la liste que
vous présentez vous devez compenser par
autant de femmes sur votre liste et on
arrive donc à une situation où nous
avons fait un certain nombre de
simulations ou si on avait 28 membres on
se retrouve avec des listes où vous
devez présenter 13 ou 14 femmes et 7 ou
8 hommes
et là aussi dans des fédérations ou à
jour vous avez moins de 10% de licenciés
ou 10% de licencier féminine et moins de
dirigeantes c'est une difficulté
organisationnelle dans le processus
électoral qui nous est proposé donc
la question de l'élargissement de
l'exécutif la question de non pas de la
parité en tant que telle mais de la mise
en oeuvre de cette parité nous pose des
questions parce que
les échéances sont courtes on parle de
2024 et donc ça veut dire que pour nos
fédérations nous avons deux fenêtres de
tir soit juin 2023 pour modifier nos
statuts soit descente 2023 pour modifier
nos statuts et donc nous avons engagé
une réflexion pour
trouver les meilleurs mécanismes qui
nous permettent de répondre à cette
question ou à ces questions et c'est
vrai que
sauf à tomber sur des usines à gaz parce
qu'on nous parle de tirage au sort on
nous parle de plein de choses pour
assurer ce parité ils nous sont ils nous
auraient semblé plus aisé de garantir le
principe de parité sur les listes
directement qui sont présentées et nous
nous sommes parfaitement pour ceux de
parité mais encore une fois en faisant
en sorte que la liste présentée aux
électeurs soit paritaire et là c'est
facile puisque vous avez à ce moment-là
une capacité à gérer cette parité
voilà le type de problématique de
gouvernance que auquel nous sommes entre
guillemets confrontés par rapport à la
mise en œuvre de cette loi j'y ajouterai
des éléments annexes
mais qui n'en sont pas totalement c'est
que la taille des fédérations
fait que
le processus électoral qui nous est
présenté il faut bien l'avoir en
l'esprit s'agissant d'une fédération
telle que la nôtre quand on dit élu par
ses pairs pour les entraîneurs chez nous
les éducateurs c'est 35000 éducateurs
donc c'est un premier vote avec 35000
éducateurs quand on parle de désigner
des Arbites c'est 25000 arbitres
deuxième processus électoral quand je
parlais des clubs c'est 14000 clubs à
faire voter et donc
c'est un champ lourd
que nous assumons parce que on est une
fédération importante nous l'assumerons
mais c'est un processus électoral lourd
que nous avons à mettre en oeuvre avec
tous les pièges juridiques qui peuvent
se poser sur les collèges électoraux sur
les processus électoraux qui doivent
nous amener progressivement à une
assemblée élective en décembre 2024 donc
voilà aujourd'hui l'appréhension que
nous avons de la mise en œuvre de la loi
de mars 2022 encore une fois
avec des principes que nous partageons
et encore une fois sur la
démocratisation nos amis du rugby ont
été en avance sur nous mais avec un
certain nombre de questionnements
opérationnels de la mise en oeuvre des
principes qui ont été retenus par le
législateur merci président merci
Messieurs les Présidents première série
de questions par Michel Savin
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les présidents merci pour cette
présentation alors on va essayer de se
cibler directement sur les questions et
d'être tout d'abord sur monsieur
Martinez qui qui a rappelé le
fonctionnement et le modèle actif des
élections au sein de la Fédération
Française de Rugby et je pense que c'est
bien de l'avoir fait remarquer parce que
on a vu dernièrement lors d'un vote qui
a été fait sur le référendum sur la
question qui était posée sur la
désignation de d'un président délégué de
la fédération pour remplacer le
président de la porte et ce vote la
démocratie a parlé parce que
84% des clubs ont voté et les clubs ont
voté contre cette proposition donc il y
a bien eu quand même et on voit que ce
type de consultation
fonctionne au sein de la Fédération
française de rugby vous n'avez pas
répondu mais peut-être ce sera dans un
deuxième temps à la question du
président la font sur
les discussions ou pas de la Fédération
française de rugby sur
l'éventuelle rachat ou proposeracha
peut-être même avec un associé en votre
voisin sur le Stade de France
concernant toujours le Stade de France
c'est un équipement qui va être utilisé
pour les Jeux Olympiques l'année
prochaine trois rencontres du tournoi
vont être délocalisés on annonce une un
manque à gagner de 2,5 millions d'euros
par match au niveau de la Fédération
est-ce qu'il est prévu une compensation
et partie est-ce que c'est le commit
olympique est-ce que c'est l'état est-ce
que oui y a-t-il pas de compensation et
donc c'est quand même une perte de près
de 8 millions d'euros pour la Fédération
et concernant l'élection toujours le
mode électrique revenir sur le mode
élection il est prévu donc des élections
dans quelques temps au niveau du comité
directeur donc on est bien vous pouvez
nous préciser que cette élection va
élire donc un nouveau président qui a
une durée de présidence de un an
jusqu'au renouvellement des fédérations
qui aura lieu normalement comme toutes
les fédérations en 2024 donc c'est une
élection pour un an avant de entamer une
nouvelle procédure donc c'était
simplement une confirmation là dessus
sur sur le foot monsieur le Président
vous avez précisé que les choses ont
évolué après la crise sportive de 2010
c'est que il y avait une volonté d'un
exécutif resserré avec une cohérence
dans la direction de la Fédération
Française de foot avec une volonté de
démocratie avec une élection par liste
vous avez aussi revenez de relever quand
même les difficultés que que vous pouvez
rencontrer comme rencontre déjà aussi
d'autres fédérations avec la difficulté
d'associer au sein des comités
directeurs des personnes qualifiées
concernant la parité donc est-ce que
comment comment préparez-vous cet
échange bon vous l'avez un petit peu
évoqué mais pensez-vous qu'il y a besoin
de il y aurait besoin de retravailler
cette cette loi qui a été votée sur
laquelle nous avions déjà nous du côté
des Sénats alerté cette difficulté de
parité avec les personnes qualifiées
quand on voit bien les
dysfonctionnements que ça peut produire
autre point concernant la Fédération
Française de foot actuellement les clubs
professionnels pèsent 38 % auparavant
avant 2010 ils étaient 25%, est-ce que
c'est le proportion monsieur le
Président vous paraît cohérente et quel
serait à vos yeux la meilleure le
meilleur pourcentage qui qui serait
équilibré entre le monde professionnel
et le monde amateur parce qu'on voit
bien qu'à 38% les professionnels le club
les représentants des clubs
professionnels pèsent lourd et qu'avec
le le soutien de quelques présidents de
de région ils peuvent rapidement prendre
la tête et ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
avec un président qui était issu du
monde professionnel
un président
issu des clubs pro c'est aussi on l'a vu
dans nos débats concernant le dernier
texte on avait aussi liberté que sur la
société commerciale
est-ce que
un président qui suit des clubs pro
Faustine pas les relations entre la
Ligue et avec la Ligue et la société
commerciale parce que il y a des
intérêts communs et puis monsieur le
Président du côté de la Fédération
pensez-vous que le niveau de contrôle
effectif que la Fédération Française de
foot peut avoir sur la société
commerciale vous paraît-il suffisant
aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations sur le fonctionnement de
cette société commerciale il serait
intéressant je sais pas si vous en avez
de votre côté mais qu'on puisse avoir
des informations sur cette évolution et
puis dernier point vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé la difficulté
peut-être de de sur
la parité au comité exécutif vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure les chiffres je
pense que là il y a vraiment un travail
à faire et peut-être que si vous avez
des propositions à nous soumettre c'est
des choses que sur lesquelles on
pourrait de nouveau retravailler du côté
du Sénat
et vous demander de répondre déjà à
cette première série de questions
monsieur Martinez
le sénateur donc vous avez évoqué le
Stade de France qu'elle est notre
position par rapport aux appels d'offres
qui ont été lancés qui ont été évoqués
par Monsieur président de la commission
la position Fédération française de
rugby est la suivante d'abord
notre métier n'est pas de gérer des
stades
c'est pas notre métier de base notre
métier c'est d'organiser la pratique du
rugby en France pour autant vous me
direz il y a des fédérations qui sont
propriétaires de leur stade c'est le cas
de la Fédération anglaise
qui a quand même eu du mal à passer le
covid enfin je pense qu'on devait le
savoir
puisque un PSE a été mis en place par
cette fédération et on a toutes les
raisons de penser que les charges liées
à l'exploitation du stade de trucs un
homme a été quelque part à l'origine
enfin une des origines de ce PS
cependant me poser la question si on se
concerté avec le président Diallo sur ce
sujet là on doit se rencontrer
prochainement on évoquera ce sujet on
l'a pas fait
doit se rencontrer au cours du mois
d'avril donc c'est très proche on l'a
pas fait
notre posture aujourd'hui est une
posture plutôt d'attente et de
neutralité pourquoi parce que vous
l'avez ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure
dans le les appels d'offres ont été
signifié que les matchs des fédérations
françaises de foot et des fédérations
françaises de rugby match internationaux
devrait se tenir au Stade de France
c'est que quelque part nous avons une
garantie par rapport au futur
lauréat de
l'appel d'offre dans deux appels
d'offres quand au fait que le Stade de
France sera toujours à disposition de
nos équipes pour effectivement que les
matchs correspondants se déroulent
donc voilà donc continue de cette
garantie je dirais que nous sommes
plutôt en attente alors si on vient nous
consulter mais on apportera les réponses
que nous pensons de voir apporter mais
nous n'avons pas
je dirais de doctrine
préconçues disant que nous devons être
propriétaire
accéder ou être actionnaire je dirais
plutôt d'un éventuel propriétaire ou pas
nous n'avons pas d'autres nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une
dans cette position que j'aime bien
d'attente à la fois d'attente et de
neutralité
par rapport au futur au futur candidats
de France ok le fait que des travaux
vont se dérouler dans le cadre de la
préparation du stade pour les Jeux
Olympiques et qui vont se traduire par
la délocalisation des matchs du Tournoi
des 6 Nations
je crois comprendre d'ailleurs qu'il y a
d'autres travaux qui sont prévus dans le
cadre de la desserte du Stade de France
qui concerneront qui risque de concerner
le toit des nations
donc un sujet qui est un sujet qui
a une forme de récurrence
alors nous sommes jeux sur la
délocalisation effectivement des matchs
de
2024 et les chiffres que vous avez
annoncé sont à peu près sont précisément
ce que sur lesquels on communique c'est
à dire que le manque a gagné pour match
tournoi sachant que c'est une année à 3
matchs avec une année pause Coupe du
monde dans le résultat influera ou pas
sur la recette
seront de l'ordre entre deux 2,5
millions de d'euros par match qui vont
généralement gagner qui
s'effectivement il se confirme pèsera
cruellement sur le budget de la
Fédération parce que je rappelle que le
budget de la fédération qui tourne
autour de 130 millions d'euros lorsque
nous le présentons ensemble générale il
est très proche de l'équilibre puisque
notre rôle notre rôle c'est bien de
consacrer l'ensemble des ressources aux
fonctions à nos missions et pas de
réaliser du résultat c'est pas nous ne
sommes pas une entreprise même nous
sommes gérés comme une entreprise on
n'est pas là pour verser des dividendes
d'éventuels actionneurs et on n'a pas
d'actionneurs donc on reverse en eau
club dans le cas de la boisson de budget
tout ce que nous pouvons reverser
donc on a rencontré certaines parties
prenantes pour nous il y en a trois dans
cette affaire de travaux liés aux JO
nous avons le consortium l'actuel
consortium
le ministère des Sports
et le COJO nous avons rencontré deux
parties prenantes parmi 3 nous allons
rencontrer les trois pour poser cette
question de l'indemnisation éventuelle
ou de la compensation on appelle ça
comme on veut parce qu'effectivement
c'est un manque à gagner que nous sommes
extrêmement sensibles
voilà
vous avez évoqué les élections à venir
effectivement au mois de mois de juin
la crise que nous traversons et qui a
connu en présence ici aujourd'hui on
n'était pas prémédité
nous allons opérer en
total respect des statuts de la
fédération à ce qu'on appelle la
recomplétude du comité directeur et
ensuite la désignation d'un nouveau
président
nous avons consulté le comité d'éthique
de la fédération pour connaître ses
recommandations par rapport à ces
élections dans la mesure où c'est une
première chez nous cette situation ne
s'est jamais produite
et donc
nous déclinons
les recommandations du comité d'éthique
alors c'est des élections commencent
vont-elles se dérouler
au niveau de la recomplétie du comité
directeur qui est composé 40 membres il
y a 12 membres qui sont aujourd'hui
démissionnaires donc nous allons
mettre en place cette recomplétude ce
sont des scrutins Unis nominaux ce ne
sont pas des scrutins de liste ce sont
des scrutins uni nominaux donc il y aura
autant de candidats que de personnes le
souhaitent que les candidats le
souhaitent et puis ça se passera un
assemblée générale élective sous un
format électronique et donc par rapport
à la liste des personnes qui se
présenteront ceux qui auront le plus de
clics excusez-moi l'expression mais les
deux personnes qui auront le clic seront
élus au comité directeur
ensuite il y aura l'élection d'un
président
alors les électeurs sont les clubs enfin
je le dis je le répète parce que la fête
de rugby c'est toujours les clubs qui
sont les électeurs
ensuite il y a l'élection d'un président
là aussi ne peuvent candidater
que des membres élus au comité directeur
et ce sont ils se présentent devant les
clubs et pas devant le comité directeur
et donc là aussi c'est le candidat qui
recueillera le plus de clics entre
guillemets qui sera du président voilà
comment vont se dérouler les élections
comment alors pour un an effectivement
jusqu'à
jusqu'à la prochaine chance avec qui
comme tout s'est fédérations s'inscrit
dans les six mois qui suivent la clôture
des Jeux Olympiques
pour que voilà pour que ce soit clair
monsieur le Président les 12 membres qui
ont démissionné sont les membres de
l'opposition c'est-à-dire que le système
que vous venez de décrire pourrait
aboutir alors pour un an puisque après
il y aura une élection générale mais à
ce qu'il n'y ait plus un représentant de
l'opposition dans vos comités de
direction alors il y a 9 membres de
l'opposition et trois membres qui
avaient démissionné depuis le début de
l'élection donc il y a effectivement
vous avez tout à fait raison lorsque
vous dites que le système pourrait
conduire à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
membres de l'opposition
à l'issue de l'élection au niveau du
comité directeur ou que
c'est qu'il y a 12 membres de
l'opposition
c'est que sur les sur les 12 qu'on
renouvelle il y avait trois membres de
la majorité qui ont démissionné pour des
raisons diverses voilà non ça peut aussi
conduire une croissance de la présence
de l'opposition au comité directe
monsieur le Président Diallo
oui pour répondre aux questions du
sénateur Savin sur la préparation de la
loi du 2000 mars donc et comme je l'ai
indiqué depuis déjà plusieurs mois la
Fédération a mis en place des groupes de
travail que l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour transposer les
dispositions de la loi de de mars
avec un calendrier qui devrait
permettre au comité exécutif de la
Fédération de voir l'ensemble des
préconisations fait par ces groupes de
travail arriver au comité exécutif je
l'espère au mois de mai et auquel cas il
y aurait une présentation devant
l'assemblée générale extraordinaire de
la Fédération au mois de juin
c'est le calendrier souhaité idéal
pourquoi parce qu'évidemment si
l'assemblée de juin ne permettait pas de
recueillir la majorité qualifiée
nécessaire de 66%, ça nous laisserait en
décembre 2023 une deuxième fenêtre de
tir qui permettrait de représenter un
texte sachant que si
par malheur
ces statuts n'étaient pas adoptées en
décembre 2023 ça poserait évidemment une
question puisque les élections générales
étant prévues en décembre 2024
la prochaine Assemblée Générale
Extraordinaire n'aurait lieu qu'en juin
2024 et donc là entre l'adoption du
nouveau texte la mise en place d'une
campagne électorale le délai serait
extrêmement court voire impossible à
tenir pour que les élections aient lieu
en décembre 2024 d'où cette première
fenêtre de tir entre guillemets sur juin
s'agissant de la parité vous avez évoqué
j'ai indiqué
ce qui nous semblerait une garantie de
parité c'est-à-dire de faire en sorte
que la parité soit liée à la
présentation de la liste elle-même en
excluant les personnes qualifiées ce qui
permet évidemment d'avoir une visibilité
absolue sur ce parité sans avoir à tenir
compte de des personnes qualifiées
désignées par des tiers et qui entrent
dans le comité exécutif ça nous
paraîtrait quelque chose de plus
praticable plus opérationnel tout en
permettant d'atteindre l'objectifs de
parité au sein de cette liste et donc au
sein de l'exécutif de la Fédération
vous avez ensuite évoqué la place des
clubs professionnels donc effectivement
après la réforme de 2010 et la crise de
2010 il y a eu ce très fort qui a
conduit les clubs professionnels à
disposer de 37% au sein de l'Assemblée
fédérale et donc une place significative
qui je dirais correspondait à deux
éléments c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui les
clubs professionnels constituent
la majeure partie de l'économie du
football c'est là que l'économie entre
guillemets se génère je rappelle
d'ailleurs que ce économie profite à la
Fédération puisque par convention
financière 2 et demi pour cent des
revenus des clubs professionnels sont
reversés à la Fédération annuellement et
donc mieux le football professionnel se
porte mieux la fédération se porte
elle-même alors vous avez évoqué ma
potentiel conflit d'intérêt puisque j'ai
effectivement effectué une partie de ma
carrière au sein de l'univers
professionnel
j'ose espérer qu'en vendant Président on
se plie à l'intérêt général et que son
origine n'est pas un élément qui nous
colle à la peau comme un sparadrap et
j'espère que même dans cette position
d'un trimestre je remplis cette mission
d'intérêt général
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure tout en
venant du pôle professionnel j'ai eu
l'occasion de présenter les contes de la
Fédération déjà à deux reprises et à
deux reprises le football amateur a
battu les records historiques d'aide
donc d'une certaine manière il n'a pas
eu à se plaindre pour l'instant en tout
cas de oui
Michel ça va juste une précision
s'agissante se place vous m'avez demandé
si les le club professionnels
garderaient le même pourcentage alors je
veux pas puisque les travaux ne sont pas
terminés mais l'orientation c'est une
baisse du pourcentage des clubs
professionnels au sein de l'Assemblée
fédérale
je pense qu'il y a une forme de
consensus qui est en train de se
dessiner pour faire baisser se
présentation
j'ajoute que dans le mécanisme
c'est-à-dire que quand vous présentez
des statuts à une assemblée
extraordinaire vous devez avoir 66% des
voix ça veut dire que vous demandez
à une assemblée
qui agit sous des statues actuelles
de certaines d'une certaine manière de
scier parfois un peu la branche sur
laquelle certains sont assis donc c'est
une opération délicate à faire et donc
il faut trouver les équilibres les
consensus pour recueillir cette majorité
qualifiée de 66 %, ce qui n'est pas la
chose la plus aisée sur lesquels il faut
évidemment à essayer de tenir compte des
intérêts des uns et des autres pour que
les uns et les autres veuillent bien
satisfaire au processus
de vote auxquelles nous sommes
contraints enfin monsieur le sénateur
vous avez évoqué je crois la question de
la société commerciale
qui évidemment a un sujet très
structurant dont votre assemblée a eu je
pense monsieur le Président à connaître
juste pour rappeler
société commerciale à ne surgit pas de
nulle part elle surgit d'une double
crise qui a connu le football
professionnel d'une part comme beaucoup
la crise du covid puisque nous avons été
le seul pays à arrêter nos compétitions
en Europe
pour s'agissant du football
français
l'arrêt des compétitions s'est traduit
immédiatement par la rupture des
contrats de télévision des clubs
professionnels 200 millions d'euros de
pertes immédiates et de un sujet qui
nous était plus propre c'est la faillite
de notre principal diffuseur qui avait
souscrit des contrats à hauteur de 3,2
milliards sur quatre ans et qui a versé
200 millions
donc rupture des contrats télé faillite
du diffuseur à hauteur de près de 3
milliards et donc dans ces circonstances
on peut comprenait qu'évidemment les
clubs professionnels se sont trouvés
dans une situation de fragilité
économique majeure et que a été proposé
une solution innovante qui consistait à
partir de la ligue professionnelle
à créer une filiale commerciale dans
laquelle un tiers en l'espèce un fond
est venu prendre 13% de cette société
commerciale
amenant à l'occasion 1,5 milliards
ce qui a permis au club français de
pouvoir faire face à ce double crise
covid faillite du diffuseur alors
aujourd'hui où on en est cette société a
été constituée avec
là aussi je veux le rappeler peut-être
quelques garde-fous posé par le
législateur je pense notamment à un
plafonnement du pourcentage à
plafonnement du pourcentage que un fond
peut prendre dans cette société
commerciale donc ça c'est garde-fou en
termes d'actionnariat et deuxième
élément entre guillemets de garde-fou
c'est que c'est une filiale à 87% de la
ligue professionnelle donc là il y a
déjà une capacité d'action mais que la
ligue professionnelle est elle-même une
sub délégation de la Fédération ce qui
veut dire que en bout de course la
Fédération garde la main
potentiellement sur l'ensemble du
dispositif
ce société je dis est en cours de
constituer et ça va être le cénacle ou
va se préparer la prochaine séance
majeure c'est-à-dire l'appel d'offe des
droits audiovisuels de la Ligue 1 du
football français qui devrait avoir lieu
à l'automne 2023 et donc c'est les
équipes de la ligue les le font avec son
expertise qui vont préparer ce appel
d'offres majeur puisqu'il doit se
situer dans une trajectoire de
croissance pour pouvoir répondre aux
échéances qui seront celles de cette
société commerciale c'est-à-dire les
remboursements
de l'apport fait par le fond
et donc il faut être dans une
trajectoire de croissance pour pouvoir
faire face dans des bonnes conditions à
cet aspect dernier point sur le cessé
c'est que dans les statuts de société
commerciale la Fédération escalyptée via
son président et membre des
conseils de
supervision au sein de la société
commerciale donc nous apprenons en
marchant puisque ce sont des marches
entre guillemets novatrices au sein du
sport français mais qui ont répondu je
lisais à une problématique ponctuelle de
crise et qui doivent maintenant nous
permettre d'avoir un retour sur
investissement pour permettre au
football français d'avoir une croissance
dans les années qui viennent
deuxième série de questions avec nos
rapporteurs sur de la mission
d'information sur les Jeux Olympiques
Claude Kern puis David hassouline
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
présidents déjà merci pour vos propos
liminaires
vous avez noté que la co-construction
d'un modèle de gouvernance partagée à
responsabilité répartie entre l'État le
mouvement sportif les collectivités
territoriales ainsi que les partenaires
du monde économique a été le scénario
retenu
via la mise en place de l'Agence
nationale du sport
la réforme de la gouvernance du sport
repose aussi
ceci en contrepartie d'une plus grande
responsabilisation et autonomie du
mouvement sportif sur la rénovation de
l'exercice de la tutelle de l'État sur
les fédérations sportives et sur une
transformation substantielle du modèle
fédéral en matière de transparence
plus qu'un objectif de gouvernance
partagé je pense qu'il serait plus
pertinent
d'envisager une notion de gouvernance
coordonnée quel est votre position
comment cela peut-il être mis en oeuvre
efficacement selon vous ça c'est ma
première question ensuite il ne
faudrait-il pas avant toute chose
envisager et élaborer un grand projet
construit pour le sport de demain avant
d'ajouter des réformes de structure
comment envisagez-vous cela car l'un des
enjeux majeurs de la rénovation de la
gouvernance n'est-il pas de prendre en
compte de nouveaux acteurs de nouvelles
pratiques et de nouvelles organisations
et technologies dans un écosystème
complexe plus ouvert que j'avais que
jamais où tout est connecté
et puis je ne peux m'empêcher de vous
parler du projet de loi relatif aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale viennent de se
mettre d'accord sur ce projet de loi à
l'article 12 nous avons notamment mis en
place la création d'une billetterie
nominative
dématérialisation et infalsifiables pour
les grands événements sportifs
présentant des conditions particulières
en termes d'organisation et de sécurité
un dispositif qui doit s'appliquer à
partir de juillet 2024 un dispositif qui
est le fruit des travaux du Sénat suite
aux incidents survenus au Stade de
France lors de la finale de la Ligue des
Champions rapport dans le co-auteur et
notre président Laurent Lafont
la Coupe du monde de rugby 2023 devrait
d'après ce que j'ai noté d'ailleurs déjà
satisfaire à ces critères
mais ma question est différente et je
dirais simple et direct quels sont
selon vous les matchs Ligue 1 Top 14 ou
autre qui devront bénéficier de ce
dispositif à partir de juillet 2024
oui ce n'est pas trop seulement en
qualité de rapporteur sur sur le suivi
de la préparation des Jeux Olympiques
que je voulais poser des questions
plus globalement
au jus de plus en plus admiratif de
du sport du rugby
même si
je suis un passionné un fondu de
football
et donc c'est de sport qui nous sont
présentés dans leur gouvernance sont
suscite beaucoup d'intérêt parce que ce
sont probablement les deux facettes des
des sports collectifs les plus
suscitant le plus de passion d'émotion
de de rencontres
collective et donc elles ont un effet
très important
sur
pédagogique
sur la société elles sont aussi le
reflet de cette société
et on a eu le sentiment avec les crises
de qu'on a appelé de gouvernance mais en
réalité on a eu le sentiment que
vivant comme des corps
autonomes quelque part aussi
de suivez pas les évolutions qui
percutaient l'ensemble de la société
comme tout un tas d'autres corps ou de
métiers ou ou de la société on a vu
comment tout un tas de révolution à
l'oeuvre dans la société avait percuté
toutes les institutions et
beaucoup de de secteurs de notre société
alors ma première question c'est
et liée déjà à
une actualité brûlante
qui a été évoqué dans l'hémicycle la
réforme des retraites reportant l'âge de
la retraite à 64 ans impact énormément
le mouvement associatif et les bénévoles
qui sont le cœur le cœur de de ce qui
fait vivre au quotidien les milliers de
clubs dont vous avez parlé
qu'il soit de rugby ou qu'il soit de
football puisque on sait très bien que
beaucoup de de français de françaises
passionnés de ces sports au moment de la
retraite s'engage
bénévoltement pour
aider dans les associations sportives à
la prise en charge des enfants à la
prise en charge des jeunes à tout un tas
de choses l'arbitrage et autre chose et
c'est bénévoles à partir du moment où
ils partiront à 64 ans avez-vous évalué
puisque ça a été fait aussi globalement
pour le mouvement associatif et bénévole
par
je crois le CSCE
pour vos pour vous
avez vous évalué l'impact le manque que
ça que cela peut générer ou est-ce que
c'est quelque chose
qui vous est passé au dessus et que vous
n'avez pas encore regardé de plus près
ensuite il y a le deuxième impact c'est
qu'on est dans une société marchand et
de pensez-vous pas que vous avez un rôle
comme fédération représentant d'intérêt
général
à ne pas apposer des garde-fous dans la
course folle en avant
qui pour générer
de l'argent et même le rugby est impacté
aujourd'hui mais le football
particulièrement
crée des situations qui ne sont plus
tenables parce qu'elles rendent en
contradiction
avec
l'état d'esprit même qu'on veut donner
aux jeunes quand on leur dit de faire du
sport mais aussi la santé des sportifs
c'est-à-dire que la
multiplication des matchs
qui se sont multipliés probablement je
ne sais pas par combien mais au moins
par deux si ce n'est pas trois par
rapport à une époque sur des êtres
humains qui sont restés globalement avec
les mêmes métabolisme
crée une situation qui devient de plus
en plus problématique pour voir des
blessures on voit des fins de carrière
précoce on voit des traumatismes sur le
long terme avec cette exigence de
toujours
dans l'économie française et la
rentabilité on présure des gens bon ils
ont des conditions de travail parfois
pénibles on en a parlé beaucoup dans
l'hémicycle mais dans le sport ça existe
aussi avec des sportifs qui sont d'abord
des êtres humains
vous avez été percutés donc par cela
quels sont vos approches de cette
régulation de cette course
au fric
l'égalité homme-femme vous avez été
percuté ça a touché l'ensemble des
secteurs vous y répondez par la parité
est-ce que ça suffit
parce qu'il y a aussi un rôle
pédagogique à lutter contre le sexisme
dans le sport qui est très très fort
dans le sport masculin comme vous le
savez l'homophobie ça a été révélé le
racisme beaucoup et notamment de façon
absolument intolérable dans des stades
qui peuvent
proférer chanter des insultes racistes
voire envoyer des bananes etc qui sont
des insultes à l'humanité
et
je voulais finir en vous demandant
concrètement parce que à chaque fois
qu'on a abordé cette question des droits
que je trouve exorbitant pour le pour
par exemple le service public qui ne
peut pas diffuser de sport
de football parce que ça coûte trop cher
et que c'est quand même un problème
parce que l'équipe de France certes
étant clair avec TF1 donc heureusement
mais que le service public puisse jamais
concourir et peut être sorti bientôt y
compris du Tournoi des six nations
faut-il laver l'exclusivité parce que
des règles sont en train de changer me
posent problème et
l'argument qui a souvent été donné
c'est que
cet argent finalement revient
au mouvement amateur et que cet argent
généré par les droits profitent
finalement au sport amateur ce qui est
vrai ce qui est vrai est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quels sont les critères
comment est redistribué au club amateur
parce que
le sport amateur mais vous devez avoir
des mécanismes comment ça arrive
concrètement les pourcentages les règles
que vous avez mis en place et la
dernière question votre rapport avec
League j'ai l'impression
que vous pouvez
être un très bon régulateur
rappelant à chaque fois l'intérêt
général comme fédération par rapport au
lit qui sont en espèce de syndicat des
clubs professionnels et qui
sont de plus en plus des entreprises des
fois même des tenues par défaut et des
faux étrangers et
dans ce rapport-là qu'est-ce que vous
pensez qui pourrait être modifié pour
que vous ayez plus de poids parce qu'on
a le sentiment que peut-être que c'est
l'inverse qui est en train de se passer
avec une plus grosse emprise de ses
professionnels voit le rôle même si on
peut pas le réduire à ça de Aulas dans
toute cette crise
le la on n'a pas le sentiment qui vient
la fédération mais qui vient plus
des clubs et donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez quels sont les
rapports et comment pensez-vous qu'il
faut faire pour que ce soit la
fédération qui garde le la du label de
l'état d'esprit du football en France il
peut y avoir des questions similaires
pour le rugby mais je connais pas
je vais vous laisser répondre à ces
questions
je vais essayer de répondre à
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
je pense que c'est la torkerne
qui nous a évoqué la question de la
gouvernance partagée coordonnée la ns
j'ai noté aussi sur le projet fédéral et
une question sur la billetterie donc je
serai assez rapide et puis je vais
peut-être que je laisserai président
répondre
sur la gouvernance partagée sur l'agence
nationale du sport
c'est une innovation de gouvernance qui
a été introduite qu'elle mettait autour
de la table effectivement toutes les
parties prenantes notamment les
collectivités locales qui sont en fait
le principal financeur du sport français
et qui se trouve à ce conseil
d'administration et qui est devenu la le
pilote un petit peu de l'ensemble des
financements du sport français donc de
ce point de vue là j'ai envie de dire
l'objectif est atteint parce que il y a
eu cette capacité à faire dialoguer des
gens qui ne se rencontreraient pas
forcément directement dans ce type de
cénacle deuxièmement les moyens ils sont
liés notamment aux grandes compétitions
je pense aux JO qui a conduit à une
mobilisation des pouvoirs publics dans
cette période particulière qui nous
amène jusqu'en 2024 mais pour lesquels
j'ai un point de vigilance c'est l'après
2024 pour savoir si la mobilisation des
pouvoirs publics sera aussi importante
poste 2024 lorsque les lumières
s'éteindront et dans notre
responsabilité de dirigeants sportifs
c'est l'héritage que nous dansons
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui se passera
après 2024 troisième élément pour moi de
réflexion c'est
s'agissant du financement le constat que
aujourd'hui 99% pratiquement des revenus
de cette agence sont publiques et que la
le passage d'un financement public à
un financement provenant des entreprises
reste à construire et donc ça c'est un
sujet je pense de réflexion sur cette
gouvernance et que d'ailleurs
parfois
la Cour des comptes totalement je crois
c'est penché sur cette question
importante
sur le projet je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui me concerne la Fédération a obtenu
un agrément pour développer tout un tas
de pratiques
moins connus que le football à 11 mais
nous avons en charge
le Footnet le beat soccer le foot en
marchant qui permet une vraie
fidélisation
d'un certain nombre de dirigeants de
clubs donc je pense que là les choses
sont complètement prises en compte et
nous sommes dans l'évolution de la de
l'ensemble des pratiques et de se
développements d'une sorte de sport plus
loisir et moins compétitif qui attire
des publics beaucoup plus différents
enfin toujours rapidement sur la
billetterie
nominative à les mises en place
évidemment sur un certain nombre de
grandes manifestations qu'elles soient
internationales de l'équipe de France
des Coupes d'Europe et ainsi de suite
mais effectivement elle n'est pas me
semble-t-il au niveau de la Ligue 1 ou
de la Ligue 2 encore mise en place
systématiquement donc là il y a voilà
que sur certains matchs bon bien
évidemment comme vous le savez avant
chantre il y a une rencontre avec les
entre les clubs les autorités de police
les préfectures pour pouvoir déterminer
les degrés de dangerosité de telle ou
telle rencontre et donc de mettre à ce
moment là les moyens entre guillemets
soit en force de l'ordre soit en
préparation de ces rencontres pour
qu'elles se déroule dans le meilleur
contexte c'est de sécurité possible
sans vouloir y revenir mais la finale de
la Ligue des Champions a été la
démonstration d'une de ces difficultés
puisque nos amis
anglais par culture ou par parce que ils
ont été trompés ce sont retrouvés avec
des billets effectivement où se
dématérialisation de la billetterie n'a
pas été pleinement prise en compte et
donc on s'est retrouvé avec des
difficultés à entrer du stade
je vais peut-être laisser le président
puis je répondrai
[Musique]
je pense que le président Diallo a
répondu
aux questions du président du sénateur
bon d'abord je suis beaucoup moins
compétent que lui en matière d'ânesse je
le dis de manière très très simple
au niveau de
au niveau de la Fédération française de
rugby nous travaillons bien sûr avec LNS
dans le cadre de la Coupe du Monde
2023 mais aussi dans le cadre des aides
nous avons été
servi de test
à la distribution CZ directement auprès
des clubs et organisé par la Fédération
française de rugby je dirais que de ce
point de vue là les choses sont de
peut-être considérées comme un succès
parce que la proximité
nous appelle la proximité dans
l'organisation qui a été mise en place
de la distribution des aides qui
s'appelait donc sur cette proximité a
permis peut-être de mieux répondre aux
finalités aux finalités de des aides en
question c'est à dire en adressant
directement les clubs ce qui était pour
nous enfin que ce qui est à mon avis un
élément fort
s'agissant de la de la gouvernance
coordonnée entre les fédérations et
l'État
je dirais que les choses d'abord il y a
des choses qui existent
c'est d'abord le taux de dispositif
légal qu'on a évoqué la loi de mars 2022
en fait partie il y a aussi des des
domaines de
d'intersection et quand je dis des
demandes intersections nous avons je
pense dans nos fédérations tous nos
directeurs techniques nationaux qui sont
des
conseillers techniques de sport et qui
sont des cadres d'État et nous avons
dans nos fédérations un certain nombre
de cas d'étages je crois qu'elle a la
Fédération nous avons une
autour de 45
qui
porte le double message je dirais à la
fois
de l'État et de la
et de la Fédération
donc
travailler peut-être à davantage de
coordination pourquoi pas je crois que
c'est un peu ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure lorsque j'ai raconté mon arrivée
à la fédéral à la Fédération c'est à
dire que
peut-être se poser la question lorsque
de nouvelles élections ont lieu lorsque
des élections ont lieu lorsque de
nouvelles équipes arrivent qui est un
travail avec s'organisait par le sanwaf
ou par l'État je ne sais pas
pour que
[Musique]
quelque part l'information minimale
et les attendus des uns et des autres
soient connus de manière à ce que
effectivement les choses se déroulent
avec une forme coordinaire de
coordination que tel que était évoqué
tout à l'heure et j'insiste là dessus
parce que je crois que c'est aujourd'hui
un déficit qui existe dans en tout cas
pour l'expérience que j'anais et quand
je parle de mon expérience je parle de
l'expérience de l'équipe je parle pas de
mon expérience personnelle mais de
l'expérience de l'équipe nouvelle qui
est arrivé aux affaires
le besoin d'information d'une
information minimale était réelle
sur le billetterie ben nous je pense que
tout le monde a fait les mêmes les mêmes
progrès la digitalisation aidant mais la
billetterie électronique sous format
électronique est apparu effectivement
elle est mise en place dans le cadre de
la Coupe du Monde 2023 avec le tracing
enfin le traçage
qui était évoqué
elle est mise en place
pas totalement mais enfin disons que
elle sera la mise en place sera achevée
pour les matchs de l'équipe de France
les équipes de France dans le pour la
prochaine saison à l'issue de la Coupe
2023 et je pense que là aussi comme pour
la Fédération Française de foot parmi
les clubs pro c'est de top 14 pro d2
certains nombre d'entre eux sont déjà à
ce niveau là mais je pense que
il était facteur que les choses se
développent même si le foot n'est pas
tout à fait le rugby dans ce domaine là
c'est le rugby n'est pas tout à fait le
foot plutôt excusez-moi ce domaine-là
sans pour autant
mais tout ça tout ça pour dire que
effectivement
nous vivons la modernité nous suivons la
modernité comme elle doit être doit être
suivie
voilà je pense avoir répondu aux
questions
donc je vais essayer de répondre
aux différentes interrogations qui ont
été posées
à monsieur le sénateur tout d'abord sur
le bénévolat
juste pour situer l'importance du
bénévolat donc j'ai dit qu'on avait à
peu près 2 millions de distanciers on a
400000 bénévoles dans le football
et sur les 400000 bénévoles il y en a
plus d'un quart qui a plus de 50 ans
donc
pour rejoindre votre préoccupation c'est
évidemment un sujet
d'intérêt alors les causes
de la désaffection elles sont multiples
il y a beaucoup de rapports qui ont été
faits autour de cette question de
l'engagement bénévole qui pensait
modification
en toute transparence pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas pu encore tirer des
conséquences d'une
report de l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
et quel est l'incidence que ça pourrait
avoir sur l'engagement de nos bénévoles
mais compte tenu
encore une fois du volume un très
important des béneurs c'est évidemment
un sujet qu'on suit avec ou qu'on suivra
avec attention parce qu'on organise nous
près d'un million de matchs par an et
donc ces matchs ne s'organiseraient pas
sans l'engagement de ses bénévoles donc
ça c'est un sujet entre guillemets
devant nous pour voir effectivement les
effets de la réforme de l'âge de départ
à la retraite sur l'engagement bénévole
ensuite vous avez évoqué les questions
de la multiplication des matchs
je voudrais pour aller de pleinement
dans votre sens qu'effectivement le
sujet de la santé des sportifs c'est un
sujet de préoccupation mais je voudrais
peut-être élargir à l'occasion de se
répondre moi je suis très demandeur très
demandeur de pouvoir de régulation parce
que la vraie question finalement elle
est celle-là et on l'a vu et à
l'occasion par exemple de la tentative
de création d'une super ligue privée en
Europe c'est que il doit y avoir un
une coordination à pacte de confiance
entre les gouvernements et les autorités
sportives parce que dans une économie
ouverte
une fédération qu'elle soit
internationale ou nationale n'a pas tous
les pouvoirs et donc si l'on veut avoir
une capacité de régulation il faut avoir
la sécurité juridique qui va avec et ça
je pense que ça dépasse d'une certaine
manière
le simple
pouvoir d'une fédération et c'est pour
ça que je pense que la question du
législateur soit national et ou européen
me paraît essentiel parce que la
question qui est posée c'est quel sport
on veut pour demain est-ce qu'on veut
une américanisation du sport européen et
auquel cas on applique un dispositif que
l'on connaît aux États-Unis qui a ses
vertus notamment celle de sécuriser les
actionnaires du sport dans un système
fermé ou vous avez la garantie de votre
apport ou nous souhaitons
philosophiquement par notre culture
préserver un modèle sportif européen
mais pour préserver ce modèle sportif
européen faut-il encore que il y ait une
capacité de régulation et cette capacité
de régulation elle dépend des
ententes entre gouvernement je pense
notamment au niveau européen pour savoir
de quel outil on peut disposer pour
plafonner par exemple un nombre de
rencontres par an pour plafonner des
masses salariales pour avoir plus de
transparence financière pour mieux
garantir la santé des sportifs en
coordination avec les règles générales
des sociétés avec les règles générales
du droit du travail et donc ça je pense
que c'est une réflexion au sens noble du
terme politique
sur l'avenir du sport en Europe et
j'attends moi avec impatience la
décision de la Cour de Justice des
l'Union européenne qui à travers les
plaintes qui ont été déposées sur la
Super League privée va je pense donner
un arrêt de principe qui va poser les
bases d'une jurisprudence qui
s'appliquera à tous en Europe et qui
nous donnera je dirais la ligne à suivre
et les moyens qui seront affectés pour
pouvoir garantir la préservation d'un
modèle sportif européen
sur les questions que vous avez évoquées
d'égalité racisme homophobie bien
évidemment je ne peux que vous rejoindre
sur la nécessité à la fois de condamner
et de sanctionner là dans ces
domaines-là il y a une nécessité de
coordination entre trois acteurs les
fédérations ou les ligues
la police et la justice et par
expérience je constate que selon les
époques la coordination se fait plus ou
moins bien
et l'école
et donc je dis qu'elle a aussi sa
nécessite des mobilisations très
importantes pour à la fois être en
capacité d'identifier les fauteurs de
troubles de les arrêter et de les faire
condamner et que cette mobilisation
encore une fois parce que lorsqu'il y a
une un événement qui attire l'attention
mais en lumière fait qu'il y a une
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
sur ces sujets et puis que le temps
passant parfois il y a une
démobilisation qui fait que
ce circuit entre tes trois acteurs
fonctionnent de manière moins optimale
et il y a un bon indicateur c'est les
interdictions administratives de stade
où on voit que selon les époques vous
avez des pics et puis ça retombe et en
tout cas nous laisse très loin de nos
voisins anglais par exemple en termes
d'interdiction de stade enfin la
dernière question que vous avez posée
c'est sur les diffusions en clair donc
là il y a déjà un décret me semble-t-il
qui existe pour me protéger un certain
nombre de compétitions sur ces
diffusions en clair
avec là aussi l'équilibre qu'il faut
trouver parce qu'on sait très bien que
l'économie de l'audiovisuel entre une
chaîne en clair qui se rémunère sur de
la publicité et une chaîne par
abonnement où ce sont les abonnés qui
font que les différences de mon temps
sont évidemment extrêmement différents
à ce titre là où va l'argent ce que
c'est je crois la question que vous
posiez et bien cet argent qui est
destiné au football amateur en fait il
se répartit où il est réparti sous la
forme de critères nous avons créé au
sein de la fédération un fond d'aide au
football amateur qui sur la base de
projets nous permet de financer des
projets de club donc je prends des
exemples on a ce fonds se divise en
différentes sections à une section
équipement une section transport une
section emploi donc quand vous êtes par
exemple dans l'équipement et certains
d'entre vous je pense sont des acteurs
ou des élus locaux et bien ça donne la
capacité à la Fédération d'apporter une
contribution financière pour la création
d'un équipement public des vestiaires un
terrain et donc cet argent à la demande
d'un club il monte un dossier avec sa
collectivité et la Fédération abonde
le transport ce sont notre contribution
à l'achat des minibus des voitures pour
l'ensemble de nos équipes de jeunes qui
puissent se déplacer sur les territoires
et de la même manière en matière
d'emplois sur les territoires je pense
dans nos départements dans nos régions
et bien là aussi sur la base de dossiers
constitué par nos clubs par nos League
ou nos districts et bien nous avons une
capacité d'abonder pour mettre le pied à
l'étrier d'un certain nombre de de
personnes d'employés pour venir abonder
sur leur rémunération pendant un an deux
ans trois ans ce qui permet de
professionnaliser nos territoires et
donc c'est comme ça que se répartissent
nos fonds et puis avec des aides
directes au club sous forme comme ça
existe dans le monde professionnel d'une
aide annuelle qui vient porter sur les
clubs participants notamment à des
compétitions nationales c'est comme ça
que ce répartissent les centaines de
millions que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
bien dernière série de questions vous
êtes nombreux à vouloir prendre la
parole je vais vous demander d'être
synthétique et rapide parce qu'il est
déjà 11 heures on commence avec Jean
Raymond Gonnet
merci Président je le saurai je vais
poser une question à chaque à chaque
président la première égard au rapport
amicaux que j'entretiens avec mes
collègues Max Brisson et Pierre uzuya je
commencerai par le ballon qui rebondit
dans tous les sens
pour parler diffusion le tournoi des
destinations est une voilà un événement
majeur
il se dit c'est la rumeur mais il se dit
de façon insistante qu'il cette
diffusion pourrait faire l'objet d'un
allotissement
ce qui signifie en clair pour parler de
diffusion au clair que les matchs de
l'équipe de France seraient diffusés en
clair mais que les autres matchs dont
dépendent souvent le résultat de
l'équipe de France serait à ce moment-là
mis à disposition ou en tout cas
forcément ouvert un appel d'offres avec
des chaînes payantes ou des plateformes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
cette rumeur ou l'infirmer et comment à
votre avis préserver l'unité de la
diffusion parce que s'il n'y a plus
d'unité de diffusion au sein du tournoi
des 6 nations ça perd un peu de son
charme ou alors ça va coûter cher pour
conserver ce charme
la seconde question
s'adresse donc à la Fédération Française
de Football par la voix de son président
par intérim Philippe Diallo et que je
remercie de sa présence également
le monde professionnel se nourrit du
monde amateur c'est une évidence mais
c'est non seulement une évidence mais
une caricature dans notre pays puisque
le joueur le plus payé au monde est
français qui a été vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure il y a 35000 éducateurs en
France il y en a un jour qui a commencé
à amener Kylian Mbappé au football et a
fait la star qu'il est pour aujourd'hui
arriver à gagner
6 millions d'euros minimum par mois ce
qui ce chiffre lancé dans l'état actuel
de notre pays ne manque pas de résonance
c'est une chose et dès que le monde
amateur a quitté le stade
pour acclamer ses idoles qui le font
rêver
dès qu'il rentre dans son club après le
match et qu'il boit une bière c'est
encore autorisé dans son club là on
entend beaucoup de critiques vis-à-vis
du monde professionnel alors ma question
est simple est-ce que vous l'avez déjà
abordé et je ne suis pas sans savoir le
travail qui est fait au sein de la
fédération par la Ligue de foot amateurs
et notamment le par le versement du Fafa
mais comment voyez-vous l'articulation
et quelles idées novatrices
pourraient-ils y avoir de cet
articulation fondamentale entre la
Fédération Française de Football le
monde amateur et le monde professionnel
parce qu'on sent bien qu'aujourd'hui
c'est articulation elle est pas vraiment
là et si j'osais les choses
les meilleurs joueurs du monde
viennent maintenant en grande partie de
notre pays la meilleure équipe nationale
est vraisemblablement une des meilleures
vous l'avez dit dans notre palmarès
l'équipe de France mais en revanche
on se met des bâtons dans les roues
puisque que ça soit fiscalement ou même
dans des oui d'autres conditions légales
on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour que le
football professionnel en France ne soit
pas forcément au niveau où il devrait
être quand on sait le réservoir qu'il
est au niveau mondial
Sabine
Messieurs les Présidents les crises de
gouvernance que traversent certaines
grosses fédération
donne pour le moins l'impression d'un
entre soi
déconnecter des aspirations nouvelles de
nos concitoyens et donc un besoin
évident de réforme
j'avais une question sur la parité mais
monsieur le Président Diallo vous nous
avez expliqué les difficultés liées au
processus électoral donc encore du voilà
du chemin à faire et qu'en est-il des
autres fédérations
le contrat de délégation de service
public a duré déterminée mise en place
par la loi principe de la République
a-t-il changé la nature des relations
avec l'État où tout état de cause il
semblerait que la ministre actuelle soit
très impliquée dans la gouvernance des
fédés
et les différentes affaires
le modèle actuel des faits qui sont pour
les plus grosses devenus des sociétés
économiques qui brassent des millions
avec à leur tête un dirigeant bénévole
est-il encore viable
[Musique]
une question enfin plusieurs questions
sur les comités d'éthique des
fédérations françaises de foot et de
rugby qui ont joué un rôle important
dans le développement et la résolution
des dernières crises donc selon vous les
moyens financiers et d'actions mises à
la disposition de ces comités d'éthique
sont-ils suffisamment garantis
leur indépendance devrait-elle être
renforcée et à votre sens pour une plus
grande transparence ne serait-il pas
intéressant de rendre leurs avis publics
je vous remercie
oui merci monsieur le Président beaucoup
de questions ont été posées beaucoup de
réponses ont été apportées donc je serai
relativement court merci messieurs les
présidentes une question concernant les
supporters le rapport réunit en mai
remis pardon en mai 2020 par marge
buffet Sacha Ollier comptabilisé à
l'époque 55 associations à gré de
supporters ce faible nombre tient en
grande partie au fait de la procédure
d'agrément
qui est peu avantageuse justement pour
pour ces groupes là ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il serait peut-être
opportun de pouvoir mieux intégrer les
associations de supporters notamment
dans la gouvernance pour faciliter
ensuite les rapprochements entre les
fédés les League et évidemment les
supporters mais permettre aussi parfois
d'éviter un certain nombre d'incidents
qu'on a pu voir au cours des dernières
années et une dernière petite question
que que font aujourd'hui je sais qu'il y
a des choses qui qui se font en ce sens
là vous fédérations dans la lutte contre
le racisme on a vu depuis ce matin
des propos pour prêter à l'entraîneur du
PSG je sais que ça dépend pas
directement des fédérations mais le
débat va resurgir du racisme dans le
sport et j'aimerais vous entendre sur
cette question là sur ce qui est mis en
œuvre dans vos fédérations respectives
je vous remercie
[Musique]
Olivier Pacaud oui merci président alors
on a parlé de gouvernance d'éthique mais
le président Diallo a rapidement parlé
des excellents résultats de l'équipe de
France de football donc depuis 98 et
puis il y a quand même eu les années 80
aussi
notre ami
Jean Raymond Hugonnet à lui parler des
résultats un petit peu moins bons des
clubs
les bons résultats ils sont peut-être
liés parfois une gouvernance une éthique
pas forcément parce que les bons élèves
enfin ceux qui réussissent ce
sportivement ce sont pas forcément
éthiquement toujours modèle on a plein
d'exemples mais la réussite sportive de
l'équipe de France c'est valable aussi
au rugby d'ailleurs elle est liée à sa
formation et vous avez prononcé le mot
éducateur on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
la formation et moi je voudrais vous
poser une question sur la formation
parce que on a pendant longtemps parlé
des centres de formation français qui
étaient des modèles entre guillemets qui
exportent dans l'Europe entière je
dirais pas dans le monde entier mais
presque et or les jeunes ont beaucoup
évolué les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont
plus ceux qui rentraient dans les
centres de formation dans les années 80
alors je voudrais savoir au niveau de la
Fédération Française de Football si vous
même que vous avez fait évoluer votre
façon entre guillemets de de soutenir de
je ne trouve pas mon le verbe mais pour
que les clubs fassent évoluer leur
formation on a quand même un vivier tout
à fait extraordinaire aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui partent très
jeunes à l'étranger ils vont compléter
leur formation ailleurs mais à la base
tout s'est fait en France et quel est le
secret en fait de cette formation
française qui a su qui a su évoluer
parce que ceux qui ont gagné la Coupe du
monde en 98 c'est pas les mêmes que ceux
qui l'ont gagné en 2018 le le la notion
de collective collectif à beaucoup
évolué le foot est devenu un sport
individuel collectif entre guillemets et
ça je pense que il y a quand même chez
vous
quelque chose que vous avez su faire et
donc moi je voulais savoir quel est
comment ça se passe au niveau de la
formation qu'est-ce que vous impulsez
merci monsieur le Président remercier
les deux présidents de fédération parce
que je crois que
si toute la jeunesse et tous les
amateurs de sport regardent les
champions il y a aussi les dirigeants
qui regardent les présidentes fédération
et on peut pas dire qu'on n'est pas
traversé des gammes de certaines
turbulences avec des comportements qui
manquaient un petit peu d'élégance dans
tous les sports d'ailleurs et que c'est
je crois quelque chose de préjudiciable
d'ailleurs même pour l'engagement
associatif ou responsables de dirigeants
qu'on a pu être chacun notre tour il y a
une question qui avait été un petit peu
abordée par haswing vous avez pas
répondu et je crois qu'il concerne à la
fois le foot et le rugby c'est les
relations entre les fédérations et les
ligues
est-ce que vous êtes des présidentes
fédération c'est-à-dire de rassemblement
d'associations ou bien plus près de
gestionnaire de société
privé qui gère des montants
considérables donc c'est
sûrement des positions peut-être pas
schizophréniques mais qui qui mérite
j'aimerais bien avoir votre éclairage et
puis le dernier c'est le rapport entre
le sport que sont le rugby le foot les
sports collectifs et l'olympisme
initialement à l'origine le sport
olympique c'est des gens qui pratiquent
une discipline sportive particulière
avec un maillot blanc
pour la gloire du sport à qui on remet
une médaille on écoute l'hymne à la fin
de l'épreuve ce qui est quand même tout
à fait différent des sports d'équipe ou
en se bat pour son maillot l'hymenait
jouer avant on a une unité de temps et
d'espace pour justement mélanger les les
activités sportives de course de saut de
lancer donc je pense que ces deux
philosophies totalement différentes et
quand je vois s'immiscer un peu le
laisser sport collectif dans dans
l'olympisme est-ce que c'est pour des
raisons de rayonnement sportif ce que
c'est des raisons économiques parce que
on sait ce que représente des Olympiques
ou un problème d'image ou au contraire
est-ce qu'on devrait pas plutôt bien
montrer qu'il y a le sport peut relever
de l'olympisme et puis qu'en revanche il
y a une autre façon de le pratiquer
d'ailleurs qui qui a aussi des valeurs
de solidarité fraternité
et plus limitée je comprends et parfois
on est un petit peu d'ailleurs choqué
que des sports olympiques quand on voit
des champions qui touchent des sommes
considérables côtoyer des sportifs de
très haut niveau faisant des
performances exceptionnelles mais qui
sont dans l'anonymat le plus complet
il y a donc parfois une opposition des
gens je sais pas comment vous la
percevez
chaque gros Perrin
merci président moi je tiens à tout
d'abord à féliciter à bouffer les
présidents d'avoir pris cet intérim
parce que c'est jamais simple de prendre
un intérim on sait combien les
difficultés se disent au quotidien on a
compris que l'objectif de la loi c'était
de provoquer un renouvellement radical
des responsables fédéraux qui conduisent
à féminiser et rajeunir les dirigeants
il y a un parallélisme fort avec la
politique et je voudrais vous rassurer
parce que comme nous il y a une
féminisation importante et c'était
intéressant comme nous il y a des listes
comme nous il y a des contrôles à la
Haute Autorité de la vie publique
politique en tout cas c'est un bien et
c'est surtout un passage obligé vous
verrez que ce passage obligé va vous
permettre à un moment donné de restaurer
ou de retrouver de permettre à chacun de
retrouver la confiance
Go Sport ce sont plus que des sports dès
l'instant où il y a une compétition ça
devient des des événements qui sont
planétaires et je crois que vous avez un
devoir en tout cas vous êtes observé
vous êtes regarder et chaque fois que de
vos joueurs ou de vos équipes ou de nos
équipes de France jouent ça peut ça une
résonance internationale et c'est très
résonance on l'a retrouvé d'ailleurs
dans le Jeux Olympiques on le retrouve
en France dans le Tour de France mais on
le retrouve en rugby et en foot et en
foot et au rugby je crois que vous avez
une responsabilité forte par rapport à
ça donc simplement une question la
première moi deux questions la première
c'est sur vos licenciers qu'il faut
qu'ils aient confiance dans leur
représentants je crois que c'est
important au niveau de l'intérêt
supérieur de votre sport donc dans
quelle mesure vos fédérations même si
vous êtes en intérim mais en tout cas
s'attache à cet objectif de intégrer de
la loi de redonner confiance à ses
licenciés et une deuxième question
subsidiaire
mais qui est importante aussi que nous
avons évoqué avec Michel Samain c'est la
situation de Madame Hardouin
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est une joie pour moi en tant que
sénatrice de LoL Loire-Atlantique et des
lunettes d'avoir devant moi les
présidents de la Fédération française de
rugby puisque Nantes accueillera
certains matchs en septembre prochain et
celui de la prés de la Fédération
Française de Football pardon puisque
nous accueillerons dans quelques mois
maintenant les des épreuves de football
féminin à Nantes
et petit quart d'heure chauviniste mais
je suis content que ce soit d'autre que
moi qui le disent non étant final de la
Coupe de France mais je crois que chacun
ici suit avec passion les exploits des
footballeurs nantais juste un mot parce
que vous savez qu'un Nantes le monde du
football a été un peu
remué par des projets imaginés par
certains de nouveaux stades à l'époque
on parlait d'un yellow Park un stade de
neuf de 40 000 places qui devaient
d'abord remplacer notre actuel stade de
la Beaujoire et qui ensuite
s'est vu imaginer quelques dizaines de
mètres de notre actuelle stade donc il
avait été imaginé il y a une période pas
si lointaine à Nantes d'installer deux
stades lundi 37000 places à côté d'un
nouveau stade de 40000 places tout ça
avait beaucoup fait parler à l'époque
dans la presse spécialisée ce qui est
intéressant et c'est pour ça que je vous
interroge c'est que la présidente de la
métropole avait fait état à l'époque de
ses échanges avec le Kojo
lui disant qu'il ne serait pas possible
d'accueillir les Jeux Olympiques sinon
tu n'avais pas un nouveau stade
la suite de l'histoire vous la
connaissez sans doute le projet de
nouveau stade a été abandonné des
travaux sont actuellement réalisés sur
le stade de la Beaujoire et Nantes
accueillera bien ses épreuves de
des Jeux Olympiques pardon de football
féminin dans le cadre des Jeux
Olympiques
et donc ma question est de savoir dans
quelle mesure vous êtes associé vous
fédération sportive j'ai bien entendu
monsieur tout à l'heure vous n'étiez pas
des gestionnaires de stade mais vous
êtes quand même des instances
compétentes qui connaissaient avec une
certaine finesse les équipements
sportifs nationaux et donc c'est vrai
que on ne peut être qu'interpellé par ce
type de va-et-vient
d'instance internationale qui ont des
injonctions parfois un peu particulières
et qui représente des investissements
colossaux pour les collectivités que
nous représentons nous les
parlementaires et les sénateurs
donc voilà c'était ça ma question dans
quelle mesure vous êtes associé à ces
réflexions vous instance nationale avec
les instances internationales et
notamment le comité d'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques pour permettre aux
collectivités d'ajuster au mieux les
investissements qu'elle doit faire et
personne ne le conteste pour accueillir
de grands événements comme ceux que l'on
s'apprête à accueillir dans les
prochains mois
oui bonjour Merci monsieur le Président
Diallo ma question était toujours sur le
football féminin vous avez parlé de 100
millions d'euros de reversement au
football amateur et je m'interroge sur
leur ruissellement jusqu'au petit club
pour exemple nous avons un tournoi
U13 de pour le comment le développement
du football féminin je et donc nous
accueillons un tournoi U13 le 30 avril
et qui accueille des équipes de de l'OM
de du Paris Saint-Germain du FC Lens et
donc la demande a été faite d'une
subvention c'est un budget de 25000
euros pour un petit club ce n'est pas
rien et en fait le district le district
n'a pas donné suite et c'est un peu
dommage parce que comme le disait
monsieur Hugonnet c'est vraiment le
berceau de nos futurs champions les
petits clubs merci à vous
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
aller très vite parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de questions je vais d'abord remercier
les présidents pour les réponses qu'ils
ont apportées à mes collègues je vais en
poser une peut-être que vous allez
qualifier de secondaire mais qui me
semble être de plus en plus dans
l'actualité du sport professionnel c'est
la prise en charge psychologique des
professionnels ça devient finalement il
y a un tabou qui est peu à peu en train
d'être levé et plus de plus en plus de
sportifs témoignent de de leur détresse
psychologique ou en tout cas de leur
mal-être est-ce que c'est une question
que vous traitez est-ce que cette prise
en charge en tout cas pour les aider et
d'actualité dans la gouvernance de vos
fédérations voilà je pense qu'il faut
anticiper sur sur ces questions parce
que elle commence à arriver de plus en
plus dans le débat public merci beaucoup
Michel legier
merci monsieur le Président j'irai droit
au but Messieurs les Présidents comment
avez-vous vécu les interventions de la
ministre des Sports dans la gouvernance
de vos fédérations respectives merci
question courte mais réponse
voilà moi je voudrais rajouter deux
questions
d'abord monsieur Martinez dans votre
propos liminaire vous avez fait une
remarque en disant qu'on a peut-être
commis des erreurs et vous parliez de
l'équipe de direction est-ce que vous
peut-être pourriez nous en dire un peu
plus sur ces erreurs telles que vous les
voyez aujourd'hui et Monsieur Diallo
vous n'avez pas répondu sur le Stade de
France Monsieur Martinez a répondu et
qu'elle est la position de la FFF sur le
Stade de France
je vais essayer de répondre quelques
questions plus donc mon collègue le
président Diallo répondant je suppose
soit au même soit d'autres questions oui
on a probablement probablement commis
des erreurs
ça fait écho aussi à la question qui a
été posée relative à la crise de la
gouvernance
ce que j'aurais tendance à dire c'est
que la situation que nous que nous
vivons aujourd'hui à la Fédération
Française de Rugby
et pour moi en tout cas quelque part le
produit de notre gestion
on ne peut pas s'exonérer
des responsabilités
de ce qu'on dirige une fédération et
c'est peut-être parce que nous n'avons
pas su
adapter notre mode de gestion certaines
situations que nous en sommes dans un
ensemble aujourd'hui
alors vous dire les erreurs dans le
détail c'est très difficile je pense que
c'est l'accumulation d'une approche d'un
mode de fonctionnement qui a conduit à
cette à cette situation
et comme je dis nous en sommes
responsables
y compris
je dirais d'une d'une forme de
personnalisation du pouvoir sachant que
le pouvoir s'exprime de manière très
différente en fonction des personnes
vous le savez aussi bien que moi mais
c'est aussi peut-être parce que on n'a
pas su
soit s'opposer
soit prendre les prendre des décisions
qui ont conduit à la situation
d'aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'il faut
aussi qu'on connaît
qu'on prend un peu de la hauteur c'est
difficile pour moi du matin
mais que
c'est important quoi c'est important
je répondrai aussi à une question
qu'elle a répondu le président Diallo
tout à l'heure sur les relations entre
les fédérations et les ligues
je pense que on a tous noté que la loi
du mois d'août 2021
qui a consacré la notion de sub
délégation des feders
quelque chose qui à mon avis étant
extrêmement positif
je dirais que l'important
c'est quelque part le cadre le périmètre
de cette sub délégation
et je pense que nous avons à travailler
dans ces directions-là parce que on sait
bien que délégation est un choix est un
choix de dans le cas présent de la part
de la Fédération
une sub délégation rentre dans ce qui
peut être subné ou pas de subir en
fonction de ce que l'autorité a été
établie qui a défini la loi a décidé et
je pense que dans ce domaine-là nous
avons beaucoup de précisions à porter et
la relation ligue fédération vit
grâce à cette supériation alors
aujourd'hui au niveau de la Fédération
francophon au niveau du Mondial rugby
cela passe par ça se concrétise par une
convention qui est passée entre la
Fédération et la Ligue qui traite de
sujets financiers bien sûr
qui est aussi des équipes de France et
qui traite aussi de de la formation de
rugby français pour faire écho au fait
que le rugbyman d'élite provient du
monamateur mais enfin je pense que le
cadre
gagnerait être précisé serait beaucoup
plus simple et ça beaucoup plus simple
quant à sa mise en œuvre
cela diffusion du Tournoi des 6 Nations
d'abord je confirme effectivement les
propos qui ont été
évoqué tout à l'heure qui ont été
prononcés c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui bon
vous savez que
le transcination aujourd'hui la
diffusion de ton assination a été repris
par une société
qui s'appelle SNRL qui habitué
l'ensemble des droits de diffusion des
équipes de France
masculines féminines et U20 un moins de
20 ans ce sont les trois principales
équipes de France
[Musique]
dans le cas de l'ensemble des nations
composant le toitination donc je vais
pas les rappeler je pense que vous les
connaissez tous
et que
cette société qui a vu arriver le fond
là aussi en fond le fonds
cette société a comme objectif de
d'optimiser j'aime bien ce terme
optimiser
les droits issus de la diffusion des
matchs et la question se pose
effectivement sur les matchs des équipes
de France qui sont protégés par les
décrets qui ont été bouquets tout à
l'heure et les autres matchs
constitutifs de la compétition de
destination où là effectivement la
question se pose sachant que l'audience
est très différente match équipe de
France l'audience moyenne et de l'ordre
entre cette autour de 7 millions de
spectateurs les autres matchs tournois
l'audience moyenne est entre 1,5 et 2
millions de téléspectateurs dans les
audiences différentes pourtant les
conditions conséquentes parce que c'est
loin d'être
mais la question effectivement se pose
aujourd'hui de voir si
on essayait d'élargir à l'ensemble des
matchs de des équipes de France et je
vous rappelle que certains matchs équipe
de France se sont cryptés aujourd'hui
les matchs détournés d'été si vous avez
regardé à tourner des phrases Japon
les derniers France Japon ils étaient
cryptés donc ils passent sur la chaîne
Canal+ ou pour pas la citer
l'idée d'essayer de voir si l'ensemble
des matchs de France serait diffusée en
clair
à contrario les matchs des autres
équipes d'après les autres compétitions
du tournoi ne serait concernant les
équipes étrangères ne seraient pas
diffusées en claires c'était
effectivement une piste mais aujourd'hui
il n'y a aucune décision mais c'est une
piste que truc pardon
on va laisser répondre les présidents
donc
je serai direct quand je répondrai à la
question comment avons-nous perçu les
interventions administrées sports
et d'un son rôle de tutelle
voilà
non non non non non non c'est pas beau
tout c'est pas du tout non je suis je
pense que dans son rôle de tutelle voilà
[Musique]
bon je répondrai pas sur les supporters
parce que bon je pense c'était plutôt
adressé au monde au monde du foot
oui la lutte contre le racisme
tout ce qui est
on essaie au niveau de la Fédération
Française de Rugby à travers ce qu'on
appelle nous la c-3pr
d'être très actif
nous sommes à zéro tolérance ce
domaine-là
nous avons été moteur au niveau des
fédérations pour dans tout ce qui est le
signalement
des événements
ou des situations qui
caractérise ce qui a été évoqué
nous avons
un service une élu qui est chargé de ces
choses là et je vous assure que elle est
très très attentive à ce que ces sujets
là soit traités alors il y a le racisme
il y a tout ce qui touche
à la pédophilie enfin tous les problèmes
que l'on connaît
sur lesquels nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants
nous avons une action de formation et
d'information auprès de auprès des clubs
et puis dès que nous avons décidément
mais nous les traitons avec
remonter vers les organes de justice ou
de police qui vont bien selon processus
qui est établi qui est défini d'accord
avec le ministère avait les ministère
concernés des sports et de justice
donc je tiens je pense que c'est je
tenais à le dire je pense que nous
sommes plutôt exemplaire dans ce domaine
une question était posée sur
l'indépendance du comité d'éthique
sachez que le comité d'éthique la
Fédération française de rugby a un
budget propre
donc il ne dépend pas financièrement de
la Fédération
que il publie ses avis sur internet donc
ses avis sont publics
et que nous le consultons et je dirais
que la dernière crise des derniers mois
que venant de passer ont montré combien
nous consultions et combien nous
suivions les avis formulé par le comité
d'éthique
ce qui est pour nous on a les mains
alors je dirais pas de
d'assurance quelque part par rapport à
la qualité de gestion de la crise parce
que il est toujours difficile de prendre
du recul de la hauteur lorsque nous
sommes totalement immergés en situation
et nous passons que nous pensons que le
comité d'éthique
à travers ses avis nous aide énormément
dans cette dans cette situation
voilà
[Musique]
le rapport avec l'olympisme alors c'est
un rapport qui est un peu un peu subtil
et compliqué il faut savoir que
si vous demandez un joueur de rugby
professionnel
quel serait son Graal
c'est une médaille olympique c'est bien
sûr gagner la Coupe du monde mais c'est
aussi une médaille olympique
et donc
si vous demandez bon Antoine Dupont qui
est un peu con aujourd'hui il vous dira
moi je j'aimerais bien
être
gagné de médailles olympiques donc c'est
et donc le rapport c'est davantage les
joueurs je dirais
qu'il établissent plutôt que les
fédérations
vous savez que le rugby à sa place
aujourd'hui dans le même pays c'était
évoqué donc sport d'équipe à sa place
donc par opposition sport individuelle
telle que vous l'avez décrit
ça ne m'a pas incompatible parce que je
pense que les Jeux Olympiques
constituent aussi un peu la
célébration du sport mondial et que le
rugby qui est un sport qui qui compte
qui certes à sa coupe du monde mais je
pense que beaucoup d'autres sports leur
coupe du monde y compris la de
l'athlétisme ou leur champion du monde
mais que le rugby soit associé à cette
célébration du sport mondiale moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
aussi parce que les joueurs derrière
sont assez effrayants sont plutôt très
friands de cette forme de reconnaissance
de la performance
je reviendrai un tout petit peu sur les
bénévoles parce que c'était évoqué
largement par le président Diallo
à peu près 15% de bénévoles enfin je
c'est sur 300 licences un peu plus de
300 licences pour cent ça nous fait
45000 45000 bénévoles
on ne connaît pas l'impact de la
retraite pour autant ce que je peux dire
c'est que
sans eux et on le sait tous le sport
français ne serait pas ce qu'il est la
limite n'existerait peut-être pas
nous avons essayé au niveau de la
Fédération nous essayons de la
fédération de les accompagner autant que
faire ce peu en mettant en place des
dispositifs
de formation et je pense au bénévole qui
sont plutôt éducateurs entraîneur
et nous avons pour se faire mis en place
une ce qu'on appelle une filière
formation qui est composée de 200
personnes 200 individus qui sont
répartis de manière assez homogène sur
le territoire français et qui sont là
pour
apporter les éléments de formation c'est
ces éducateurs
en essayant de faire en sorte que de
moins perturber
les éducateurs
faire en sorte que ceci puisse assister
à se dire c'est le formateur qui se
déplace dans le club c'est pas
l'éducateur qui se déplace ce qui est un
élément qui apparaît comme ça qui est
partie du bon sens mais qui est
extrêmement efficace aujourd'hui sur la
formation nous avons déployé
simultanément en réseau de
d'apprentis qui sont dans les clubs là
avec plutôt d'une vision administrative
spécialiste administrative et l'ensemble
de ces de ces ressources de ses
compétences accompagnent les bénévoles
et on peut penser que ça nous aide à la
fidéliser même si effectivement on sait
bien que chaque fois que on a
malheureusement du fait de son âge un
bénévole qui disparaît mais on a du mal
à le remplacer que c'est une population
qui a plutôt tendance à se réduire dans
le temps
au niveau de la
de l'image de la féminisation
je pense être évoqué bon au niveau du
rugby nous sommes comme
au niveau du foot la féminisation est
quelque chose qui s'opère à grands pas
paradoxalement qui va très vite
ceci est dû aujourd'hui
d'abord
à ce sport qui qui retrouve un peu ses
origines puisque on s'aperçoit que
l'origine des joueuses plutôt
universitaire
on les retrouve notamment en université
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que on sorte
à travers cette féminisation à des
problèmes de structure de d'installation
puisque qui dit féminisation dit
vestiaires différents enfin dit tout un
tas de contraintes sur les structures et
on se heurte et on fait appel notamment
aux collectivités territoriales que vous
représentez pour que
quelque part il nous accompagne dans
cette féminisation on a d'ailleurs signé
une convention avec landaise qui a cette
vocation là mais c'est un vrai sujet qui
constitue quelque part une forme
d'obstacles à cette à cette féminisation
voilà je ne sais pas si j'ai oublié des
questions je pense
[Musique]
merci je vais essayer de pas redire ce
qu'a dit le président de la fédération
de rugby mais peut-être de de compléter
peut-être du point de vue du football un
certain nombre de points
le premier point je voulais évoquer
c'était pour bien attirer l'attention
sur le la difficulté du modèle
économique dans lequel nous une
fédération est placée il s'agissant de
la Fédération Française de Football
d'une certaine manière mieux on fait
notre travail et plus on est en
difficulté je m'explique moi j'ai 20
sélections nationales et plus on
développe les pratiques foot en marchant
foot golf Footnet plus je féministe
c'est-à-dire que je double mes équipes
nationales donc mieux on fait du sport
pour tous et plus je perds d'argent
pourquoi parce que sur plus de 20
sélections nationales j'en ai une
qui gagne de l'argent c'est l'équipe de
France à masculine toutes les autres
toutes les autres perdent de l'argent et
donc puisqu'on est en transparence j'ai
l'équipe de France féminine qui a joué
une demi-finale de l'Euro en Angleterre
donc une performance sportive de haut
niveau économiquement c'est 2 millions
d'euros en moins pour la Fédération donc
c'est ça la réalité du modèle économique
et c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on bouge des
curseurs c'est important de prendre à
avoir en tête cet élément là ça renvoie
les questions des diffusions au clair
pas en clair parce que on a un modèle
économique qui est encore une fois comme
je l'ai dit mieux vous faites votre
travail et plus vous êtes fragilisé et
que dans un contexte d'inflation que
vous que vous connaissez évidemment
c'est une partie difficile à jouer cet
élément là sénateur aussi se renforce au
niveau des clubs professionnels puisque
là aussi dans une économie ouverte
libre circulation des sportifs ce sont
des systèmes fiscaux et sociaux qui
rentrent en concurrence au-delà des
compétitions sportives je prendrai qu'un
exemple en la matière en Allemagne les
charges patronales elles sont plafonnées
à 12000 euros par mois alors si vous
gagnez 1500 ou 2000 euros ça se voit pas
et donc vous êtes dans la même situation
qu'un travailleur allemand mais par
contre pour des activités de talent et
donc le talent est rémunéré fortement et
bien si vous gagnez plusieurs centaines
de milliers dans l'écart de charge il
est
des multiples et donc c'est ce qui
explique que moi j'étais avec l'équipe
de France en Irlande au dernier match
qualification sur le terrain j'ai un
joueur qui joue en France
celui que vous avez cité tous les autres
jouaient à l'étranger c'est pas qu'on
est moins bon c'est qu'on est dans des
compétitions internationalisées dans
lesquels nous ne disposons pas forcément
des mêmes armes que nos voisins
européens c'est pas un jugement de
valeur en ce qui me concerne puisqu'il y
a des systèmes de protection sociale
qu'on pourrait poser mais c'est un
constat qui fait que cette situation là
elle est défavorable au football
français
de la même manière aujourd'hui ce
phénomène se prolonge avec la
professionnalisation du foot féminin
nous avons dominé à travers un certain
nombre de nos équipes le football de
club féminin aujourd'hui nous commençons
à voir une telle partie en Espagne une
autre partie en Angleterre donc le même
phénomène produit les mêmes effets donc
c'est ce contexte là que je voulais
préciser parce que il est très important
et ce qui veut dire que pour nos
fédérations nous sommes aujourd'hui à
mon sens confronté à une nécessité de
réflexion sur l'évolution de notre
modèle économique certains ont évoqué la
digitalisation nous avons évidemment à
une réflexion sur cet aspect là parce
que
on est après des années de croissance
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
stagnation des ressources et un effet
ciseaux avec des charges comme je
l'indiquais qui naturellement
augmente et donc ça c'est un sujet ce
qui me concerne de réflexion voire de
préoccupations pour l'avenir
on a évoqué la question des équipements
et des stades
nous n'avons pas parti pris au cahier
des charges des grandes fédérations
internationales qui font un cahier des
charges pour leurs compétition soit
d'euros soit de Coupe du Monde quel
détermine indépendamment des fédérations
y compris des pays hautes qui sont
sollicités
s'agissant de la question des comités
d'éthique non une situation similaire à
la Fédération de rugby avec pour nous
quand même la point d'attention c'est
celui que la ministre vient de de lancer
ce Comité national d'éthique qui doit
rendre des travaux justement sur ces
questions de gouvernance et d'éthique et
nous pensons contribuer à ces travaux à
qui je crois devront être rendus en
septembre et qui pourraient en tout cas
être le signal d'une prochaine évolution
législative que vous l'avez entendu moi
j'appelle de mes vœux sur un certain
nombre de sujets parce que je pense que
là aussi si on veut être toujours
en phase avec son époque il est
nécessaire d'avoir des adaptations
législatives qui nous permettent de
toujours être en phase d'adaptation
je me prononcerai pas pour mes collègues
sur la formation
quelques mots sur la formation
effectivement la France peut
s'enorgueillir d'un système de formation
je pense qui est
envié par le monde entier et qui
reposait sur une philosophie assez
simple au début pour ceux qui ont initié
au début des années 70 c'est peut-être
formé un sportif et un citoyen donc on a
appelé le double projet ce double projet
là aussi la France peut s'enorgueillir
parce que c'est la France qui l'a
portait au niveau européen et ça fait
désormais partie des objectifs de la
Commission européenne et donc de ce
point de vue là je pense qu'on a bien
œuvré parce que pour être un bon sportif
il faut être aussi bien dans sa tête et
donc je pense que la les choses ont bien
été faites nous sommes nous maintenant
dans une phase 3 j'ai envie de dire
puisque à ce premier double projet on a
jeté une troisième un troisième pilier
à partir du constat où ces jeunes qui
sont dans des académies dans des centres
de formation ne vivent pas exactement la
même vie que les autres adolescents du
même âge et ça dans leur épanouissement
personnel il nous semblait qu'il fallait
corriger cette forme d'isolement et
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place un
troisième pilier qu'il a leur permettre
s'ouvrir à la société on amène des
jeunes de centres à l'opéra au théâtre
on les fait participer à des opérations
humanitaires pour qu'ils vivent
une vie
correspondant à des jeunes du même âge
et pour ça on a passé tout un tas de
conventions de partenariat avec beaucoup
d'associations donc ça c'est
l'encadrement entre guillemets des
jeunes et puis forcément ça passe aussi
par des éducateurs
c'est la qualité de la formation des
diplômes qui sont exagérés qui font que
nous avons une capacité d'encadrement
très significatif pour je dirais même
l'ensemble du sport français aujourd'hui
il y a à peu près 150 000 salariés dans
le sport dans l'ensemble en France 60%
sont des éducateurs et donc c'est par ce
biais-là qu'on a en capacité de
maintenir un niveau d'exigence et de
performance très importante je fais une
petite parenthèse
parlementaire sur la question de la
formation professionnelle parce que on a
quelques soucis avec France compétences
pour bien faire comprendre la
spécificité de la carrière sportive et
de la nécessité d'encadrement et donc de
la formation professionnelle parce que
si on veut maintenir un haut niveau de
formation il faut des encadrants et ces
encadrants ils vont en partie sur ces
diplômes et donc il faut les financer
par de la formation professionnelle et
quand on est bénévoles
le taux d'employabilité ou critères
d'employabilité n'est pas forcément le
critère le plus pertinent parce que
c'est des gens qui ont déjà un métier à
côté et donc qui vont faire de la
formation pour améliorer leurs qualités
leurs capacité d'encadrement et pas
forcément pour avoir un job puisqu'ils
l'ont déjà et donc c'est des aspects
qu'on a dont on a besoin avec France
compétences notamment de leur faire
partager pour que ils soient pleinement
en phase avec notre activité
l'Olympie j'ai la même réponse il y a
nos grands joueurs
qui gagnent des sommes importantes mais
il a envie de jouer les jeux olympiques
voilà c'est un rêve et il a envie d'y
être et nous on souhaite évidemment
qu'il y soit et je dois avouer que pour
les sportifs français participent aux
Jeux Olympiques ça reste un vrai rêve
ils ont de la notoriété ils ont de
l'argent mais participé aux Jeux
olympiques en France c'est vraiment un
quelque chose de très important je viens
d'avoir un exemple qui à mon avis
presque unique dans le sport de le foot
au moins je viens au nom de la
Fédération Française d'engager un
entraîneur pour les sélections féminines
il vient d'un pays étranger
il a accepté de diminuer sa rémunération
dans des proportions considérables
considérable pour pouvoir être à la tête
de l'équipe de France et d'avoir la
perspective d'une part de la Coupe du
monde mais des Jeux Olympiques à Paris
c'est pour ça que parfois on parle
beaucoup d'argent mais les gens qui
pratiquent le sport les sportifs les
éducateurs ils restent je pense
fondamentalement dans leur ADN se aspect
sportif de participer à des compétitions
et de ce point de vue là les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris je pense que c'est
vraiment un rêve pour l'ensemble de la
communauté sportive y compris des gens
qui sont dans le monde professionnel et
qui ont je vous disais notoriété ou
argent
ce n'est pas l'élément le déterminant
pour participer
à ses compétitions
[Musique]
prise en charge psychologique
là aussi c'est un élément qui
s'introduit désormais dans les staffs
parce que effectivement il y a une
charge mentale importante et donc dans
les stats il y a de plus en plus de
préparateurs
psychologiques pour accompagner les
sportifs c'est une vie très difficile
faite de stress de tension de remise en
cause quasiment hebdomadaire et que
effectivement
ça peut nécessiter un accompagnement qui
de commence à se faire en club auprès de
nos sélections nationales pour pouvoir
accompagner nos sportifs sur la ministre
des Sports et son implication je crois
que le président de la rugby a tout dit
donc
je n'ajouterai pas de propos
complémentaires puisqu'il est à fort
bien dit
ce qui avait à dire
sur
l'intégration des supporters puisque
nous nous avons des supporters parfois
plus turbulents que ceux du rugby
c'est un sujet assez complexe parce
qu'on pourrait se dire on va les
intégrer mais il y a un problème parfois
souvent de représentativité de ces
groupes de supporters parce que vous
rentrez adolescent ou jeune adulte dans
un groupe de supporters vous y restez
deux trois ans ça tourne beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de turnover et parfois c'est
difficile d'avoir des interlocuteurs
pérennes à la tête de ses de ses
institutions ou de ces groupes de
supporters qui puissent intégrer des
exécutifs ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas de dialogue au niveau des clubs il y
a souvent des conventions des
partenariats qui sont frais passés avec
les groupes de supporters pour avoir un
dialogue permanent avec eux au niveau
des équipes nationales ou de l'équipe de
France c'est pas le même type de
supporters vous pouvez constater que
c'est pas pareil il y a d'être dans un
club ou dans autour de l'équipe de
France pour ceux qui ont pu participer
ou assister à des coupes du monde voyez
que l'ambiance est assez différente elle
est souvent très détendue très familiale
très convivial et donc c'est un problème
encore une fois au niveau des des clubs
qui doivent gérer avec cette difficulté
de représentation de ces supporters mais
avec le souci sans cesse de les associer
parce que nous on est populaire parce
qu'on a des supporters et on est
économiquement fort parce qu'on a des
supporters donc les supporters elles
sont ils sont entre guillemets partie
intégrante de notre activité
[Musique]
voilà je pense que j'ai essayé de
répondre rapidement à beaucoup
[Musique]
alors la situation de la DG a évoquée
elle est en cours de process entre
guillemets puisque vous savez que
à la suite du rapport qui a été remis
par l'Inspection générale de
ministère des Sports la conclusion de ce
rapport visait à ce qu'elle ne conserve
pas ses fonctions
il y a eu donc une procédure qui a été
de licenciement qui a été mise en œuvre
et qui est en cours actuellement
merci Messieurs les Présidents pour les
réponses répressives que vous nous avez
apportées je précise j'ai oublié de le
dire au début que nous avions également
invité votre homologue de la président
de la Fédération française de tennis
mais qui n'a pu se joindre à nous merci
beaucoup en tout cas pour
clarté de vos propos